Jimmy car welcome to the show thank you
very much I'm uh I'm a big fan of it I'm
kind of nervous about talking to you in
a weird way because I like the show I I
really like you as a kind of cultural um
entity I think it's a really interesting
kind of Journey you've had and I get so
much from this show you know that phrase
I think you use it probably more than
any other phrase does it grow corn and
for me this show really kind of grows
corn there's so many little things that
I've taken from this that I've kind of
on oh I'm going to I'm going to do that
I'm going to do something with that so
kind of the the practical application of
the wisdom what you get out of people
seems to be um very easy to integrate
into life right so the bar's being set
high for you today then if you start
around well I mean around is
sort of what I do so the other thing is
like I I kind of get more nervous being
myself than being sort of the comedic um
Persona you know just being funny just
being on things being funny I find very
easy it's a it's an interesting sort of
Life Lesson the idea of like what do you
find easy that other people find
difficult go for that do that for a
living that's that's there's there's
going to be money there there's going to
be there's going to be some gold you're
going to be okay if you find it easy and
everyone else is going that's impossible
so you standing up in front of people
being funny I find very easy like these
kind of conversations I slightly you
slightly second guess yourself it's what
you're used to I think it's what you
spend a lot of time becoming
acclimatized to doing yeah I suppose you
know it's just that thing of I've always
said in comedy people sort of talk about
how many years they've been doing comedy
and it seems faintly ridiculous it's
kind of it's like when you talk to an
airline pilot they've got a really good
view on it they talk about how many
hours they've got in the sky and for me
like there's no substitute for um stage
time and I'm sure for you there's no
substitute for for this for actually
doing it everything else is is kind of
it doesn't matter how many years you've
had a podcast I think something about
the frequency of your show as well it's
the it's kind of it's always there
there's always something
new you talk about the most important
question to ask yourself being what do
you want yeah I mean I talk about that
an awful lot I I studied a lot of uh
studied and was very interested in sort
of NLP and that question of what do you
want in the micro in the macro being um
being the absolute key in sort of life
because people sort of um I suppose it's
it's it's that thing of going what does
something represent people someone might
say well I want a
Ferrari um but why if you if you sort of
dig a little deep you can't just ask
once what do you want well I want a
Ferrari and a Rolex and all of the
trappings but actually what they want is
status so it's kind of asking yourself
what game are you going to play I've
read a lot of that um uh Rene Gerard uh
stuff about sort of memetic desires so
this idea that you've got what you
really want at kind of a a fundamental
level it's about you and what you
perceive you should have compared to
others so this idea of kind of being
honest about what you want and why you
want it well splitting apart what is a
genuine desire that's come from you
that's been
self-authored and what is just the
things that you've taken from the way
you dealt with past trauma and what your
parents valued and what society says
that you should and the paths of least
resistance and your genetic
predisposition this beautiful quote that
says ultimately happiness comes down to
choosing between the discomfort of
becoming aware of our mental afflictions
and the discomfort of becoming ruled by
them and it's this yeah that's it's a
lot though isn't it I mean it's like I
don't think anyone gets there by the way
I think there's there's kind there's
slightly I think sometimes when I hear
people kind of interview talking about
this stuff there's a there's a sense of
oh well you know I'm enlightened now and
I know knowing that you you know you
only want that thing because you've got
that thing and I want the new iPhone
because you've got the new iPhone
knowing that doesn't really make any
difference because when you're out there
in the world you still got to live a
life and do something correct but it's
about what uh that will store book I
thought was phenomenal um the status
game I mean all these books are great
actually he's a really interesting sort
of underrated wrer he's wonderful but
that thing of like going well actually
you pick what status game you play in
you can have anything you can't have
everything it's that thing of just the
the words seem to be very important to
me the idea of saying um you can work
for anything in life to a kid as as you
can have anything is the difference
between um you know ambition and
entitlement in you know summed up was
that lovely thing you sent out the other
day yes that you know that the
difference between ambition and um
entitlement being you know ambition
ambition is when you expect yourself to
close the gap between what you have and
what you want entitlement is when you
expect others to close the gap between
what you have and what you want yeah
that thing of like agency see
seems that's very high on my list of
like getting back to what do you want
agency I want the um I want control to
be in here like I think it's better to
be a standup I mean the thing I've been
thinking about recently is um being
stoic doing less better being a stand-up
is a great job and there's so many
stand-ups that get the job of being a
standup and then they want to be an
actor and you I go you're mad that's
it's not as good a job it's better to do
a podcast than to have a TV show
and because you're in charge you're Your
Own Boss you you know kind of whe you
know cancel proof not you'd be
particularly bothered about that but the
idea of going you're in charge and
you've got agency and you can do what
you want well there's a level there's a
huge power to that there's a level of
narcissism I think that comes with
believing that you would be able to beat
somebody else at them doing one thing
while you're doing two things okay so
you think that you're going to be a
better podcaster than the guy that just
does a podcast whilst trying to do a
podcast and run a business and be on TV
and fly around the world do all of these
it's also that thing of like going if
your aim is sort of happiness I think
having a process driven ambition rather
than an outcom driven ambition like what
do you want to do rather than what you
want to be you know so that idea of
going look you do a podcast and you live
for it it seems to be pretty much all
you care about and you're loving it and
you you you kind of embody that and it's
it gets back to that Nal thing of like
what's play for you what's easy for you
what's play what's just what's fun no
one's going to put this effort in look
around look at the 4K cameras or
whatever the no one's putting this
effort in that doesn't really care about
it so someone trying to fake it and go
well I want what he's getting for that I
want the ad Revenue it's like you well
no that's the you're playing in the
wrong game there's a a really great
quote from Mark Manson where he talks
about the most important question to ask
yourself is what pain are you willing to
endure in your life rather than what
pleasure do you want because any
pleasure or any Pursuit that you want is
going to come with an in-kind payment of
pain even your stuff the the fatigue the
the road everything else but that thing
of like you know the the all self-help
is hard choices now Easy Life later
everything is the marshmallow test
everything is about saying look you know
that famous marshmallow test of give a
kid you can have one marshmallow now or
two later that seems to be a really good
indicator in life of going what are you
willing to and and and work really is
work is the sacrifice for later and it's
it's really about that time frame
probably the biggest thing I got from
this show uh and from following you was
that idea of serving yourself in 24
hours you have to serve someone what are
you going to do today that you tomorrow
will appreciate yeah because for
something about a day seems about the
right time frame like if it's if it's in
six months time and you're trying to go
to the gym and motivate yourself by I'm
going to look great in six months it's
like ah I don't know I don't know if
you're going to do that I I don't think
that's a motivator because it's written
on my fridge what would you tomorrow
want you today to do it's written on my
fridge it's a great I think there's a
book in that I I think genuine I think
it's such a a powerful you've got me
writing you have told me to write five
different books over the last week that
we've spent together but I like the idea
of that thing of going because it's it's
you know you listen to a podcast but the
book seems to be the book and the course
seems to be the thing that it's just a
way of getting all of your thoughts on
this together treatment yeah um but I
think that idea of like your the you
know what are you going to do that's
going to make you happy in 24 hours and
that's really about saying well your
Ambitions should be um feelings not
things what's the difference well the
idea that you go well how do I want to
feel is something that you go well
that's that's an ambition you have I
want to feel happy I want to feel
contented I want to feel healthy I want
to feel fulfilled uh wanting those
things wanting material things well the
reason you want the material thing is to
give you the feeling so just cut out the
middleman yeah I mean listen it's easy
for me to say I'm rich famous
baby you know it's like it's slightly
that thing of like where you're calling
from but you you just realize there's
just more stuff over dinner you spoke
about the difference between jealousy
and envy and I thought that that was
really interesting well I think that
it's a conception where I don't really
mind which word you use but Envy for me
is is good because it tells you what you
want
so if you see someone and they've got a
terrific physique and you go oh I want
to I want to look like that guy that
tells you what you want that's that's
great when you see someone with a uh I
don't know a um a beautiful girl and you
don't want him to have it but you don't
want it that strikes me that is a very
uh that's kind of um bitterness and
resentment and it's it's mean and it's
it's that that I think it's a it's a
it's a nich quote isn't it if you um uh
resentment is when you think someone has
ruined your life and there is someone
that's ruined your life it's
you so that's really I find that very
powerful the idea that's the agentic
frame again right that you're taking
control of that when you realize that it
is you that's been in control of most of
the things that have gone on that's
taking agency that's taking
responsibility but I think that we're
we're sort of set up not to do that
right we we're set like and as the
economy changes as our world changes I
think theide idea of getting a job is is
a little bit you know become slightly
Nanny State it's like well I'll get a
job and they'll pay me and then they
they'll worry about that and I'll just
do this job for them and it's like this
idea of like new jobs are happening all
the time it feels like there's a there's
a new economy kind of sprouting up and
people are doing their own thing it
feels like it's not just comedians I
mean obviously I'm uh very bought into
the being a standup comedian world but
people are doing their own thing it's
lovely yeah I I wonder talking about the
skill acquisition thing obviously the
pace that you tour at how many shows
have you done this year so far 220
something like that and there's probably
been about 250 to 280 days so far this
year yeah something like that but I make
TV shows as well so you know I keep busy
but it's you know but really if you
compare it to someone with a real job
it's not that much work because the way
that I perceive it is I work for you
know 2 hours or 4 hours a night
depending on how many shows and in most
people work 8 hours now there's a bit of
travel involved and stuff but it's it's
it's a pleasure if you find something
you love doing you never work again
that's the well I suppose if you look at
that's such a good frame to say wow 250
days of the year or 220 days of the year
and there's only been 280 days or
whatever okay well if you were to roll
that forward for any normal 9 to-5
person that's that's probably the right
number of days or maybe even a little
bit less and there's something about
taking a working class spit and sawdust
mentality into the realm where it it
doesn't seem like it's it's supposed to
be there where you actually end up
seeing disproportionate returns yeah I
suppose it's that thing of like it's
uh it's really about what you're willing
to put in as well like if you find
something that you love doing well why
would you want to stop doing that just
do do more of that and you get better it
is that thing where you go it's time in
the gym it seems that stress is very
good for us in in all areas you know
going to the gym is stressing your body
and working and coming up with new stuff
is you know you're stressing yourself
you know so that thing of like trying to
you know trying new stuff at every show
it's only you know you saw the show the
other night it's only a five minute bit
where I get out a pit of paper and try
some new jokes but that bit means that
the next tour is very easy because five
minutes at every show you you sort of
Bank a lot of stuff a bank a lot of new
ideas and you have a reason to think
about the new thing always you have a
reason to be thinking about okay what's
the new thing what's the new thing
what's a new idea for a joke what AM we
going to try tonight well that's a big
hack I think you know it's the fan
technique in order to be able to learn
it you must first be able to teach it
type thing but there's an equivalent
when it comes to personal growth as well
I think which is the best way to ensure
that you're going to continue to develop
is to have an outlet where it's going to
be scrutinized by other people like so
much of the learning and the reading and
the stuff that I do is exclusive because
I know that I need to be remotely
interesting or prepared for the next
guest that comes on well it's that it is
that thing where you go the joy of
standup comedy the feedback loop is it's
so quick I mean people just immedi and
and an audience you Lenny Bruce first
said it the audience is a genius they
know immediately that's funny that's not
funny that's acceptable that's not
acceptable they make the call on all
that stuff so you're just like
presenting stuff and going is that okay
is that all right I mean you know it's
it's really easy because you just you
write I've written so many more jokes
that don't work than you so many more
like thousands more it's that Edison
thing about I haven't failed I just
found 10,000 ways that I wasn't
successful yeah and you but you
eventually get to it and then you go
well you what's what's the stand-up
comedian kind of superpower it's an hour
maybe 90 minutes if you go and see a
live show cuz there a bit of stuff as
well but you know putting together
specials and you go right it's it's
that's kind of the best of me over the
last 18 months that's all the funny
stuff I I said in the last 18 months and
that's there for you I think it's more
relevant than music I think music is
incredibly important and should be
taught more in schools but I think
standup should be a course in schools
you think about what it's about it's
about verbal dexterity right and it's
about being able to express yourself and
it's about finding your voice and
expressing who you are and it's a
perspective on life where you're seeing
the lighter side and trying to find fun
in something that you know there's two
stories you know one story is about a
guy um himself on a train and
it's just a it's like ah I had the worst
day ever and then there's some
perspective where you go that's the
funniest story I've ever heard there's
there's something about the ability of a
comedian to kind of shift perspectives
and for me comedy has a function in
society that no one is calling which is
it's the we're pushing the Overton
window we we're always at the edge of
what is and what isn't acceptable like
no I'm not just talking about like I
happen to tell edgy jokes that's not
what this is It's I'm seeing things as
they are but kind of with new eyes
that's sort of what Comics do even the
most kind of mainstream observational
comedy have done well you're sort of
questioning the reality you're saying
well this is this is uh this is not
normal this is not how things should be
this is weird am I the only one thinking
this is it just me that kind of Trope of
comedy and it pushes what we what we
think about the world it pushes what's
acceptable Progressive you said that
comedians are often ahead of the curve
on social issues I think they are I
think like comedians really do kind
of it's the canary in the mine it's the
sort of test in the air of what you can
say and you know politics lags
behind and so does culture you know if
you want to know what are going to be
the biggest talking points amongst
normal people in about 18 months time
look at the jokes that comedians are
making today well I think there's a
there's a there's a argument to be said
that comedy lives in sort of a space
between public and private discourse and
it strikes me that there's never been a
wider gap between public and private
discourse what people are saying in bars
and homes and on social media to their
friends and and what the party line you
know you sort of the party line's pretty
strong at the moment on what you can and
what you can't say you know if you want
to see where power really lives what
can't you
say it's interesting right what can't
you say in a society what isn't
acceptable in the world you get into
very interesting topics I mean all the
stuff you talk about on Modern wisdom
falls into that sort of category of
going what should we talk about this you
know you talk about you know whether
it's environmentalism or gender or or
you know what's what's happening in the
world it's very it's very interesting to
kind of call that and to to mess around
with it so it's actually it's kind of a
great space
and comedy it sugar the pill as well you
you know it's it's almost the perfect
drug for me standup comedy because it's
the dopamine here if you don't quite
know where the line is going to come and
it's the serotonin pleasure of laughter
and going out to a live show has that
incredible sort of effect on people of
it it's a physical response I'm you know
I've said it before I I think of myself
as a drug dealer but you have the drugs
on
you that's so nice you know You' you've
got everything on you but I'm able to
sort of tease it out so I can get across
borders with no
problem it's interesting isn't it like
the best drug in the world what's the
best drug in the
world I would love to know what the
hormonal Cascade of someone listening to
a great podcast is feeling I'm going to
guess that there would be a good chunk
of Serotonin and maybe some dopamine
from I've realized something or his two
ideas that I didn't see before and
they've been tied together and they've
been wrapped up in a bow and interesting
the dopamine thing the thing that we
were discussing the other that I found
very interesting was like the idea that
you could go if you had one data point
on someone their view on abortion let's
say what else could you what else could
you figure out from that correct you
know so the the modern day I suppose it
would be modern day cold
reading right so if you know old school
cold reading was you know someone at a
sance going is anyone lost a
Mary in Catholic Island I mean
throw a
stone but the idea this kind of modern
day called reading on what do you what
do you think about brexit someone tells
you and you go I know everything that I
need to know about you yeah from that
one data so it's with podcast it's the
thing is it's about the dopamine of
going when does someone surprise you
with their view dude I I so after our
conversation we went for dinner on
Thursday and then I wrote my newsletter
based off of the inspiration from that
such a good way to judge whether or not
the content creator that you are
listening to is acting
genuinely and taking their insights from
what they truly are interested in and
being honest is when was the last time
that they surprised you with something
that they said yeah the the honesty is
really interesting because it's it's
weird being a comic because everything I
say on stage is a lie ultimately jokes
are little lies but Comics leak there's
a weird thing you can watch someone on
stage or watch you know your favorite
comic or whatever and you kind of have a
sense of who they are it just it just
happens you don't really choose your
style as a comic it kind of chooses you
it's kind it's who you are it's really
it's kind of an interesting the
caricature of the self well not even a
caricature I think there's something
about it's it's very authentic and
there's something about podcasting
especially the long form shows you can't
hide there's nowhere for you to hide so
the thing that I found kind of
fascinating about your journey um and I
you know my only critique of your show
is I don't think you ever talk about
yourself enough because it's you're
fabulous at listening and teasing things
out people and and holding a space but
you never really talk about your journey
and maybe you did in the very early
episodes and I missed them but the idea
of like going to go from a guy on love
Island running clubs to this strikes me
as a I mean you talk about agency you
you basically kind of invented a job
that didn't really exist wasn't really a
thing and and now of course you know it
is and you know everyone's got a podcast
but not like this yeah yeah it's
interesting I guess you know whenever I
sit down with someone for a long time
when you start a show you're writing on
the coattails if whoever is in front of
you you know I'm riding on the coils of
Rory Sutherland or Jordan Peterson or
Douglas Murray or whoever and
then I'm always really interested in
just making the show an amazing platform
and trampoline for the guest if I walk
away with the guest shining as much as
possible that's that's a good day at the
office for me I made this as energetic
or sedate or thoughtful or exciting or
whatever as needed to be to get the best
insights out of this spectacular person
who's very interesting and I want to
learn from that's a good day at the
office and it always inevitably puts me
in the back seat but that's how I
designed it right I designed it to not
be it's not called the Chris Williamson
show right it's called modern wisdom
because I wanted to be the most
interesting people the smartest thinkers
on the planet what have they got to say
life is hard and this show should
help that's where it is that being said
I know that after a while sort of the
cult of personality starts to kick in
and you think oh well people actually
want now not just to know about them but
to know about you I've got this
live show happening where it's me on
stage for nearly two hours just me yeah
that's Terri how's that how are you
finding the because you did the first
one on Saturday right I had a dry run
yeah assisted by some words of wisdom
from you the night before um it was good
I really enjoyed it scary I don't know
how you guys do it uh what do you mean
you just did it but it's different what
I do is I just get to Waffle what you
have to do is this unbelievably 0% fat
lean down to the nothing but muscle
bodybuilder presentation up on
stage I don't know I think it's I think
it's you know what are people looking
for really I mean with laughter they're
looking for uh it's a it's a it's a it's
a response you could kind of measure you
look at laughs per minute and go well
you're doing a great job because you're
getting the laughs per minute but
ultimately they're coming out to be part
of a crowd they could watch it at home
on Netflix but they're coming out to see
a show because they want to feel
connected what are you offering
connection people want to feel connected
and you're standing on stage and you're
saying well you're giving of yourself
here's what I learned here's what I
think and you know hopefully they they
feel like they're they're with
like-minded people they're in a room
Collective fence I think it's Tribal
isn't it it's that idea that we're we
sort of there's an illusion that we're
individuals I really like that line
there's um there's no such thing as a
baby it's always a baby and someone
caring for the baby it's a baby and a
mother baby and a father baby and a
family the babies don't exist on their
own we're all babies we all takes a
village you know if you look around
behind the cameras at the other people
that are just in the room right now
never mind the other people that work on
the podcast the idea that a standup is
standing on stage on his own it's an
illusion it's a very pleasing illusion
because we're in our heads a lot of the
time but we are searching for community
in a space where that's sort of been
lost you know that the idea that we're
kind of we've never been more connected
and never felt more alienated because
it's about the depth of the connection
in other news this episode is brought to
you by epidemic sound if you have ever
tried to put sound effects or music
behind any video you will know just how
hard it is to do epidemic sound has over
90,000 sound effects plus a vast music
library that will avoid any copyright
concerns your videos are not going to
get demonetized or infringe on someone's
copyright which happens all the time if
you're not using a professional Library
all of their tracks are professionally
produced by a diverse collection of
artists and are exclusive to the
platform if you've ever been wondering
how your favorite creators take their
videos to the next level a lot of it
comes with sound design and that is the
Sound Library selection they have access
to so many of them are using epidemic
sound and you can join them for free for
30 days by clicking the link in the
description below or going to share.
epidemicsound.com
slod wisdom and if you cancel within
that 30 days you can still keep all of
the sounds that you've used during your
trial period that's share.
epidemicsound.com
slod wisdom we spoke the other night
about the problems of the
self you have a problem or there are
there are many problems that are
associated with this obsession with the
self and the rise of the individual well
I think that's you know that's the yeah
it's it strikes me that it's uh if you
if you look at different communities
around the world you can sort of see
where the C communities where the self
is uh
is sacran and there's other places where
not so much uh you know it's much more
tribal I mean it's kind of an
interesting thought my favorite quote of
all time is William Gibson the future is
here but it's not evenly
distributed and you think wow like yeah
of course what does that mean to you
well it means that there's a Utopia in
the world I'm I'm a very positive person
I mean I really do think the world is
great and we're going to crack it I
think we may have already solved most of
the problems in the world but in in in
just particular areas right so you know
so you go to Portugal let's say go to
Lisbon now and the drug laws changed 15
years ago they legalized all drugs said
all drugs are legal and we're going to
take all the money we were spending on
fighting uh the War on Drugs which would
just patently losing we're going to take
all that money and we're going to spend
it on rehabs and we're going to spend it
on education and we're going to spend it
on uh making it easier for people to
make good
choices great and it worked you walk
around Lisbon now one of the safest
cities in Europe it's magnificent it's
bug buzzing it's it's fabulous you go
that's that's a brilliant idea why don't
we just take that and do that here it
seems to work because you know the
altern people sort of go yeah but you
know drugs aren't good and drugs I agree
I don't do drugs it's not my thing and
some people have got real issues around
them but you go but what we're doing at
the moment isn't working and that seems
to work and then you'll always have a
very small percentage of people that
have you know real problems and that's
fine but but at least if you know those
people aren't criminalized then they
don't most petty crime is drug related
so you that's a problem that's been
fixed we could just take that I think
the energy crisis have been
solved but only on nuclear
submarines nuclear submarines strike me
as that's there why is no one talking
about these people are living in tubes
with a nuclear reactor and they have
been for 50 years we've tested it and
those guys seem fine self- sustaining
much worse environment than we've got up
here where we can breathe water and we
don't need to recirculate the carbon
dioxide and it's working right there you
go there's the I mean I'm ABS I'm with
Extinction Rebellion I think there is an
environmental crisis it's awful but I
don't think the person that solves the
problem is I don't think we say in 50
years time we came pretty close there to
an environmental collapse but thankfully
someone glued themselves to the top of a
car that did it I think it's going to be
a physicist that does it right it's
going to be a scientist that has a
wonderful idea and and and does
something so it's that thing if you go
what if you care about that where should
you be putting your energy and I think
it's again it comes back to where's the
agency so that you know gluing yourself
to the top of a car is is great it's
saying look I need some this is
important something needs to be done I
don't think any politician has the
vision to do it I don't think it gets
solved through a law I think it gets
solved through science and technology
and I read um uh David deutsche's uh the
beginning of infinity that was just
blown away by what if we're the first
100 billion people that's how many
people have lived
right yeah 100 billion um I'm including
us in that yeah and it could be
trillions in the future yeah if we if we
get this right it's it's exciting right
and the idea that science is this
particular kill a meme that can you know
we've got this AI technology which
people seem scared about and you go well
maybe this is going to be the solution
people are worried about nuclear
catastrophe we've already priced in the
downside right we've priced in nuclear
war that's already a possibility why not
take the outside did you read William
MCC casal's what we owe the future did
you see that no but I I I heard people
talking about it I I haven't got around
to reading it is it is it good
interesting guy good it's it's an
important book I think to read
especially if you
tops way well that idea of like people
being people are important um temporally
and spatially yes so the idea that we're
quite obsessed with us in the west
America West Europe in our village in
our community what do we owe the future
is a very good question what do we owe
the rest of the world because the idea
that the environmental problem could be
solved by doing less and cutting back
and maybe if we live like we lived in
1985 that could cure things
I don't think it's you know the
population's out of control I don't see
any volunteers have you heard Peter
singer's thought experiment about the
drowning
child this explains the distance thing
that you were talking about very nicely
so um you're walking down the street and
you see a drowning child in the uh River
that's next to you does sound like a set
up for a joke doesn't it it sounds like
the kind of thing I would go so I'm
walking down the street so there's a
drowning child in in a river
yes okay that's the start Peter sing is
a nice softly spoken Australian man in
his late 70s I don't think that he was
meaning it as the setup to a joke but
feel free to take it for tonight okay
you if you were to walk past and not
save the child you would be seen as
abhorent right the drowning
child you're the only person that's
around here why would you not go into
the river and go and save this kid okay
now some kids are
dicks I mean let's call it let's call it
better off do I know this kid no is it
Baby Hitler no why would it be B Baby
Hitler I don't know thought experiment
go to go to Hitler okay so go what's the
uh basically he continues to use the
distance of you okay now the
river's 100 yards away now it's 300
yards away now it's half a mile away now
it's a mile away and the point is at
which distance does the drowning child
become less important to you and the
argu kind of is that there's no distance
it becomes an arbitrary an arbitrary
decision if you would save the child
that was there now you would save the
child that is on the other side of the
planet starving of yeah it's that you
get to that um I think quite quickly to
that uh what is it best things first the
is it BJ lomberg book about what we like
the idea the UN has got 148 things that
they want to do these are our priorities
and you go well you don't have any
priorities then cuz there's a lot of
things m what are the things that we
should do now that make a difference so
the simple stuff like mosquito Nets
really does make it makes a huge
difference what do what do you do
because you go well you
value you know your life much more than
you value someone's life in you know
it's interesting what we're not talking
about like no one talks about what's
going on in
Venezuela no one seems that bothered
about Venezuela at the moment and it's a
I don't know the phrase
shows brings to mind what's happening in
Venezuela it's you know the stories I'm
hearing is you know teenagers are
hunting cats in the
street people are dying of malnutrition
yeah it's like it's it's hell on Earth
that thing of like you know the future
is here but it's not evenly distributed
it goes back as well you can go back in
the past is still here it just hasn't
caught up yet yeah it's it's you know
there not everyone's kind of running on
the same system and maybe we should be
maybe you
know I mean we we live in an incredibly
privileged time and I'm big on gratitude
of like of the the opposite of kind of
uh bitterness and resentment the idea of
just going well what are you grateful
about and it's you can kind of it's ever
expanding the idea that like if I'd been
born in North Korea today never mind 400
years ago but today he's really funny
he's really good at saying you know
offensive
things I wouldn't have lived to made it
to six and a half years old yeah it's
gone it's gone that's not given your
pant for being positive and for
gratitude what do you make of this
culture of cynicism that we see on the
internet fatalism nihilism
despondency um I mean it's the
internet's a problem for me
because the anonymity is is an issue um
are you with Jordan Peterson on this
what on the he says that no one no one
should have a Twitter account that
hasn't uploaded a photo of their ID I I
I kind of would think that's be an
interesting thing to try I mean what's
the argument against that that that
whistleblowers couldn't operate well I
guess whistleblowers existed before
Twitter and they used to have to go to a
paper and the paper would then print the
story that doesn't seem like a terrible
system so we go back to that and
everyone has to upload and then you go
well you can still post you can
still do all that stuff it's just it has
to be traceable to you because we are
who we are when nobody's
watching if you want to know who you
really are be on your own go somewhere
on your own on holiday or whatever and
you that's who you are if you're driving
along and you throw the soda can out of
the window of the car that's who you
really are no one does that with kids in
the back monster but if that's if that
if you do that if that's who you that's
it's interesting to kind of note that
you know it's the difference between
character and reputation you know you
really know who you are reputation is
what everyone else thinks about you you
know who you are and
yourself it's interesting to me to to
think about
how the way that we the way that we act
when nobody is looking tells us an awful
lot about
ourselves it's that adage about
um listen to how he talks about his
mother and how he treats the serving
staff at the restaurants when you're on
dates it's like a good litmus test for
the guy that you're
dating because that shows kind of who
when the stakes are incredibly low yeah
how do you show up as a
person but yeah go back the cynicism
angle what do you think's going on I I
don't know I me I suppose it's easy it's
is easy to be kind of cynical about
stuff it's also do do people not feel
like they don't have agency you know if
we as we learn more about what's going
on in the world as we you know you're
surrounded by news stories that you can
do nothing about you know Co was very
interesting for that because it actually
affected us but normally you're reading
about an earthquake happening and you go
well this what can I do what difference
does it make it's it's beyond my control
or they're fracking for oil in Alaska
okay well no one's listening to me or
they're going to war in this okay well
I'm I'm not sure I've got a a dog in
that race but and you feel very so it's
you you you kind of get cynical about it
I think people have got cynical about
politics it feels like they need big new
exciting ideas that people can get
behind and it feels like a lot of
politics is like talking about changing
this thing a tiny little bit changing
that and it's people are kind of in one
camp or the other I wonder whether the
skepticism around the legitimacy
of
Elections is born out of this sort of
sensation people have that they don't
really have any they can't contribute
and what they do doesn't matter because
that's that's the most extreme version
of it right even my vote didn't matter
even my legitimate vote didn't matter
yeah so regardless of whether or not you
think that the voting machines are
hacked or whether or not it's it's part
of some big conspiracy which it very
well may be it definitely seems like you
could sort of extrapolate forward oh
well if what I do doesn't matter at all
this is a perfectly designed
continuation of that narrative as well
so maybe people were were primed to
believe that a little bit
more yeah I mean I think it's a it's a
very interesting point to of go well if
people don't even think their vote
counts then what you do but but I guess
if you're if you're pinning your hopes
for um self-actualization on your party
getting in it's like following a
football team it's like it's a fun thing
to do but don't don't let it take over
your life you know these are 11 guys
that don't give a about you and
they're kicking a ball around it can't
be everything it can't be the whole of
your life Politics as well can't be the
whole of your life you can't hope that
that's going to bring you everything
it's you want you want a uh a better
world but how are we going to get you
know it's a good question to ask like
how do we get a better
world um how do we how do we bring the
standard of living up what do we
actually want for the
world because it's not just more money
you see what happens when people get
more money there's just more inflation
of that hidden tax kicks in so what do
we want we want better education better
chances for everyone better
opportunities I guess it's it's like
there's a lot of stuff that everyone
kind of agrees on
right why do you think we think about
luck
incorrectly my thing on luck is like
we're we're incredibly lucky there's
certain things that we devalue right so
so um looks is a really good example
like if someone's a model and they're
they're gorgeous and they're
photographed lucky people are kind of a
bit dismissive of that if someone's born
really smart you never you're lucky you
born with an IQ of 162 bit of luck no
one thinks that we sort of the two great
myths in our society are um uh it's hard
work and talent aren't they and it's
always total it's always a mix
of the two and finding the right medium
the right Edge for you the right thing
to be doing so you go people think oh
you know Bill Gates oh he worked so hard
he used to work 18 hours a day slept at
the office he worked so hard to build
that company he's incredibly bright he
had you know it's it's always you know
the talent and the hard work you know
Michael Jordan if he hadn't shown up to
practice would be just a
guy um and also if he was living 200
years ago pre- basketball I don't know I
don't know you know that skill set is
very
particular so you what's what's what's
what's luck the everyone's incredibly
lucky I mean just to be here here is
it's beyond
right I don't know I kind of I like the
idea of just going okay look we're very
lucky we've got what we've got run with
it and also you're not going to change
it you you might that thing of like
acceptance being kind of that first step
in therapy strikes me as really sensible
just looking at what you've got and go
right this is it this is it for the
whole journey I can work on this it's
like nature nurture obviously nature
it's got a bigger effect than nurture
but nurture is the only bit anyone gives
a about cuz the only bit you can
play with yeah until I can start
fiddling with my DNA sensibly then I'm
going to be I'll be nurturing and
nurture people seem to think nurture
stops you know people seem to think
nurture and environment is the thing for
kids yeah and the right school but
really look at you as a shining example
of environment so you you put yourself
in the micro and the macro in a better
environment than you were in 5 years ago
you're not surrounded by people on love
Island you're surrounded by these
incredible intellect
and you've taken yourself out of your
where you grew up and went to University
and you've taken yourself to to Austin
because there's there's kind of energy
there and there's other people that are
trying to do the same thing as you and
you put yourself in that environment
that strikes me as as incredibly kind of
powerful but the idea that you know if
you're still hanging around with the
people you hung around with 25 years ago
and they're not adding value then what
are you doing yeah me and George had
this idea that we're going to write a an
essay on together so I'm going to try
and explain it to you now it's not fully
thought out but we'll see if we can get
there the difference between observable
and hidden metrics and how they
influence our motivation so a lot of the
time people will trade a hidden metric
for an observable metric good example of
a hidden metric would be something like
peace of
mind okay and something like an
observable metric would be money people
will happily trade something which may
be more valuable ultimately for
something which is less valuable simply
because they can measure it more
effectively yeah like time's an
interesting one because John lenon lyric
isn't it I give you everything I got for
a little peace of mind there we go that
but that it's a very interesting point
because that idea of going you know if
you can't measure it we tend to go to
what's measured correct and so the idea
of going these and but actually what
matters is it's you know emotional yeah
and there's no dashboard this is why
George tries to have a dashboard for all
of the things that he does he's got this
end of day
assessment type form custom type form
he's made himself that autop populates
to a Google sheet and at the end yeah
yeah he's he was born an incel but
managed to ascend out of it he has got
himself to the stage where he's tracking
what were the three things that I did
today what was my sense of presence how
connected was I D D D D D all the way
down and his goal is to track this over
time right to see what are the
correlations between my actions and the
way that I felt so he's trying to make
the hidden
observable and the problem that we have
is that things that really really matter
to us like connection and peace of mind
and you know dopamine and serotonin
balance throughout the day like how
content and fulfilled did I feel all of
these things they're just words
there's this nebulous ephemeral Wishy
what it's trying to hold smoke right to
try and work out what this is but money
my bank account it's good game
the number of followers I've got on
social media it's a really good
game so I'll chase down
the observable well it gets back to that
story of like what's the most successful
story in human history
money money is The Greatest Story Ever
Told because what even is it really when
you break it down it's kind of um it's
not anything and yet everyone believes
in it everyone believes in that story
and what you're getting to is what's
really important in life and the stuff
that maybe you can't measure is kind of
what matters right I wonder if there's
the this hidden observable framework
that we've got here I wonder if there's
an equivalent to do with luck so what
you were talking about is that the
actual chance of us all being here which
I did for my tedex talk I actually
looked at this it's the same likelihood
as all 7 million people in Ireland
rolling a trillion sided dice and all of
them coming up with the same number it's
astronomical it's way way way way way
more than all of the particles in the
observable universe because your
parents had to meet at that particular
ovulation cycle with that particular
sperm all the way back forget surviving
in all of the rest of it to preh
humanity correct all of the way the only
way that you're here is with the exact
precise combination of each different
iteration that goes all the way back up
had to be that sperm I find that
slightly makes my head hurt you know
that thing of Sam Harris was talking
about this recently the idea that um
maybe there's no free will maybe we have
to be having this conversation now
because when the Big Bang happened
everything rolled out this was ordained
of course Robert seol's got a new book
coming out called determined you know
Robert spolski Harvard's evolutionary
biologist he's coming on in month and a
bit and his new book is called
determined and it's uh like how to find
happiness in a life with no free will um
so it'll be interesting I think one of
the things that Sam failed at doing I'm
still like is it some people I speak to
talk about like ways that free will kind
of does come through and all the rest of
it but one of the things that I think
has at least not instructed me who has
listened to a lot of him in
is tactically how do I use the
information of a deterministic universe
to feel
more fulfilled given the fact that both
of us are such massive fans of agency
and everyone that's listening to this
podcast will be as well they want to
feel like they they're the architect of
their own life right that they are
actually able to make some sort of
imposition on the world it's very
disempowering to find that oh I'm just
just Domino number 48 million out of
today's
it it doesn't doesn't make me
feel very empowered so I want I want
someone to come in and tactically tell
me if this is the case yeah how should I
live it's interesting that thing of like
the the time scales kind of comes up and
also the idea of like what what are we
what's important here you sent out a
thing recently about you money yeah
which I thought was really interesting
the idea of like the meme of you
money the idea that you could have
enough that you could tell people to
off if that's particularly
something that you know you want to tell
people to off in my experience you
can tell people to off with no
money good luck but then there's there's
you Freedom was the next iteration
and then you got to you family the
idea that actually what really matters
is having a unit and and family I would
take in a broader sense of friends and
family having like a a catery around you
your tribe if you will around you that's
really very interesting to me of like
where you're going to play that game
where you have agency uh in the world
and the idea of going okay well there's
certain players you know Elon Musk has
got agency at a ludicrous Global level
but you know and the global leaders
great but on an individual level we all
have agency we can all we can all be you
know we can all make a
difference yeah I I really wish I really
wish I could give the gift of sort of
higher agency to a lot of people I think
it's such a the lack of I know I think
sort of the greatest gift like if you
could give your child any gift
likeability likeability goes a long way
that's Peterson's thing do not let your
children do anything that makes you not
like them like a likable child I think I
was in fear I may need to ask my mom
when I fear I was an incredibly
unlikable child and I think that that
shaped that was probably quite formative
in a lot of my experiences with other
parents with other kids do you not think
that I mean I know a little bit about
your childhood and kind of what you went
through as an only child and feeling
slightly isolated but is that not the
thing that untethered you and allowed
you to sort of fly through so true so I
spoke about this yesterday with Steven
Bartlett
that there's layers to unpacking the
things that you went through and the
formative experiences that you've had so
the first layer is you know a chip on
your shoulder about whatever it is that
happened to you so for me you know being
bullied in school being ostracized not
feeling like I was part of a group then
the second layer is alchemizing that
into something that you really care
about so saying okay the skills that I
got and the resilience that I developed
from spending so much time on my own
I've turned something that was toxic
into something which is valuable then
the layer after that is is I get to use
the chip on my shoulder and the
resentment for the people that came
before me and that caused this problem
as the activation energy to now deploy
this skill set okay so there now I'm not
only uh not only have I made lead into
gold but I've now turned this gold into
something that's useful I've formed it
into something that I can move forward
with but then the final one and this is
the really difficult one is to
realize that if the people who tormented
you are the reason that you've developed
the skill sets that you carry about then
you can't resent them you should thank
them that you genuinely should look
back at most of the things that you were
ashamed of or guilty about or fearful of
in your past and realize that that's the
Dark Side of one of the lightest and
most proud things that you've got so
overall if the challenges that you went
through formed a person that you
like those bullies in school I should
sit down with all of them and say yeah
thanks man
yeah that's uh it's very interesting to
listen to Because when you when you go
you know to go through that experience
it's it's kind of easy now you're 35
you're a grown man and you're doing
great but to sort of think back to you
are still that child yeah you're still
that lonely kid searching for connection
but is that not the whole of the show
like every episode I listen to you're
sort of there kind of looking for a hug
you're sort of you're hold meanor is I
want to connect with this person I want
to know what they know and I want to
have a friendship and it's incredibly
healthy it just seems like it's it's a
yeah everything that happened absolutely
worth it and also H what are you going
to do you can forgive them and move on
or you can hold
resentment but it's it's ultimately
that's you know what's what's the
important thing we can't measure that
metric yeah of what that forgiveness
gives you as to what that resentment
gives you but I would I'd bet the house
on the fact that the forgiveness is
lighter and breeds more activity yeah
I've been thinking recently about the
idea of
um we can't know the future and we don't
fully know ourselves and we don't fully
know the present we don't fully know
everybody else so we have to concede
that some huge proportion of our
worldview is a
delusion yeah isn't does someone talk
about the three humiliations you ever
heard of that no what's that the three
humiliations of human so it was
cernus we're not the center of the
universe and then it was Darwin we're
we're descended from animals we're not
special oh Jesus all right and then the
third one Freud our self-conscious is
running the show we don't even know
ourselves a
hell hell it's like Humanity's
really taken a combination one big hit
after another yeah those are those are
big hits and you go yeah we don't really
know ourselves but that's kind of the
journey and that's the the whole thing I
mean that's why I think not to bring it
all back to standup comedy but I do
think there's something Magnificent
about doing a bit of standup you know
going and finding your voice and what
you find funny and your sense of humor
because everyone's kind of got one right
in other news this episode is brought to
you by nomatic no literally it's
actually brought to you by nomatic that
carryon Pro is the hand luggage that I
used to transport my laptop and all of
the stuff that I brought with me to the
UK the difference between having proper
well-designed durable high quality
luggage and not is everything it makes
the difference between packing a
complete hell or actually quite
enjoyable the team of nomatic creates
the most functional durable and
Innovative backpacks bags luggage and
accessories everything from nomatic
comes with a lifetime warranty which is
exactly how confident they are in the
quality of their products especially if
you're someone that travels quite a lot
you need to make sure the luggage you're
using is high quality and nomatic is the
best that I found so if you need to
upgrade your luggage game for work for
travel or for anything else the first
place to go is nomatic head to the link
in the description below or go to
nomatic docomo wisdom and use the code
modern wisdom at checkout for 20% off
everything sitewide that's nomatic tocom
wisdom and modern wisdom a checkout yeah
I uh so this delusion thing
people people don't fully know
themselves or the world around them or
what's going to happen or all of the
rest of it given the fact that you don't
know yourself and you're deluded in some
way why not pick a delusion that is
useful to you well this is what NLP gets
you neural linguistic programming talks
a lot about
presuppositions because you can't know
you don't know it for a fact it's kind
of you know all bit of a pseudo science
so what's useful rather than think about
what's correct what's useful what makes
a difference if I believe I can do that
I can do that the belief is often the
thing that makes the
difference um H did I do that bit did I
tell you about the uh symbolic truth but
literal falsehood
framework no this is cool okay
so things can be symbolically true but
literally false and this is most
religious stories so the belief that
porcupines can throw their quills right
literally untrue porcupine can't throw
its quills like it's not a it's
not Phil the power tailor right
uh good luck America listens without
reference Phil Taylor a fat Naka dce
player Legendary dce player from from
England you say legendary I say fat Naka
but you know potato potata yeah you can
throw a a sharp thing so they can't do
that it's a useful thing to belief yeah
because they're bobbed and if they get
in you you're so not good the
belief that porcupines can throw their
quills is symbolically true in that it's
adaptive for you to believe it another
one would be that pigs are uniquely
dirty animals ever seen a c cow's pretty
dirty as well so all of the religious
Traditions that said we don't eat pigs
because pigs are uniquely dirty animals
literally false figuratively pigs do
carry a higher pathogen load typically
than other animals in their meat so by
believing that that's the case it's an
Adaptive uh outcome for you now I
learned this from Brett Weinstein six or
seven years ago right then I've been
playing with it for ages and ages to try
and think of something which is
literally true but figuratively false so
what's the opposite of this right so I
was trying to think about something
which is might be accurate to know but
unadapted Universe even if that is
literally what is true figuratively it's
an information Hazard I don't think that
it really unless you go full like Sam
Harris Enlightenment mode and get out
the other side side to no one is the
architect of their own decisions
therefore empathy and forgiveness are
much easier to come by which I don't
think like practically is is that easy
for most people to
do I I don't think that that the same as
the behavioral genetics red pill if you
believe that almost more than 50% of
what you are psychologically is locked
in and you only get to play with this
tiny little sort of cake dressing on the
top of it how many cherries do I want to
put on top of this cake yeah it doesn't
feel it's not very support
in terms of how you show up in the world
even if it's true so that's something
that might be literally true but
figuratively false and the porcupine
throwing NE qus certainly think it's a
very interesting area to sort of talk
about because it's about belief makes
such a huge difference if you believe in
something you can kind of you don't it
gives you kind of the will to do it to
give it a
go about what you think is possible what
are your dreams going to be I mean when
you started this podcast presumably you
didn't think I'll be Austin Texas
talking to the Great and the good and
trying to figure things out yeah it's
like that's why I think the book thing
is really interesting for you now of
like trying to rather than just uh at
the level of okay trying to figure this
thing out and it's kind of interesting
to chat about it's like putting down
these thoughts and going you know does
it does it grow corn what what are the
bits of wisdom that are most affected
how you live
daytoday it's why I think that the next
24 hours is really interesting yeah of
like what could you do that adds value
to you tomorrow such a lovely frame such
lovely FR you you talk about uh
disposition being more important than
position yeah what you mean by that well
listen I know some billionaires that are
pretty miserable and I know some guys
with uh boring office jobs that are very
happy I think your disposition is it's
very difficult to change but it's often
easier than changing the world you know
you are you're in your head on your own
an awful lot of the time no matter how
connected you are no matter how great
your family you're you you are you and
you know the acceptance of that
and the way that you see the world the
rose tinted glasses of looking at the
world looking for jokes is pretty
tremendous I think the thing that makes
a difference to people on disposition is
um in the most part it's gratitude can
kind of move the dial that's the thing
that seems to make a difference because
it's that thing of like if you're if
you're in a bad mood all the time you're
not in a bad mood you're an
it's the truth of it so it's go
you how are you most of the time the how
you treat a waiter or a waitress or how
you react when you get a speeding ticket
or any of those little things that CU
life is going to throw lots of that
stuff at you how do you react to it h
how how are you in the world what's your
is it a sunny disposition or are you
kind of you know are you are you are you
boring well you've been through bouts of
depression as as I have I I actually
thought throughout all of my 20s that I
was depressed I thought that that was
the texture of my mind I thought it was
locked in like the worst weed trip that
you've ever had this is me for the rest
of my life okay so I'm interested in
conflated words and I often think
depression is conflated with sadness and
sadness is much more um difficult to
admit and it's much more uh there's more
of a stigma around being I'm depressed
it's kind of there's a c certain glamour
to being depressed Loof it's sort of
this mysterious thing it's pathologized
it suggests depth yeah where sadness is
just all you sad you're sad what do
you do you got a surface level life
you run clubs I'm sure you're having a
nice time whatever but it's it's surface
level so that Depression was maybe
sadness but I think if it's
environmental if you could change it if
it's not to do with the serotonin levels
in your head and a cical embance then
it's if you can do something about it
it's sadness so assuming it's sadness
and that you can do something about it I
me listen it's people with real mental
health problems and my heart goes out to
them but for a lot of people it's just
their it's circumstantial but you went
through periods of acute sadness or
depression however you want
to label it and yet you've managed to
get yourself to a stage largely
anxieties being the big is really my um
drug of choice yeah and anxiety I
think's got I think there's a gift in
there I think the gratitude that I have
for anxiety is it's the flip side of
creativity correct that your mind is
racing and sometimes you're trying to
solve a problem in the future because
you don't have anything to do now it's
why people talk about you know I'm so
happy when I exercise because you're
giving yourself a problem right now and
your mind is dealing with whatever
lifting that up and putting it down yeah
you put 120 kilos on a on a bar you're
not thinking about much else other than
I really need to get this off me yeah
that that thing of like that simple
thing of going you probably don't have
enough to do if you're anxious about
silly things in the future or the um I
mean I'm I'm I get very tied up
with counterfactuals and wondering about
about what might have been and what
should I have
done and you know it kind of links to me
to that weird thing of like no one's
scared of falling off a cliff worried
about
jumping there's a there's there's kind
of a weird thing of going what have i'
done something different what if i' I
could told you that that you've heard
that Douglas Murray thing about in life
we must choose our regrets right yeah I
mean you can have anything you can't
have everything
yeah yeah that uh what could have been
we can't split test life we can't go
back yeah and give this another crack I
tell you for a guy with a sunny
disposition it's a very serious
conversation isn't it yeah I quite like
this I feel this is very I feel like in
the moment to Calla it feels very
revealing to have this conversation
because it doesn't feel unlike the
conversation we had at dinner the other
day but it is that thing if you go it's
kind of showing more of yourself than
you you know normally it's just dick
Jokes wait until people see you haven't
got pants on
underneath uh cut to the white yeah
it needs to be very wide um yeah I so
I'm interested in
this if anxiety is your malady your
mental malady of choice yeah and yet
you've managed to get yourself to
a state where you are in a sunny
disposition at least some nonzero amount
of the time well yeah sorry just to go
back to because I'm still thinking about
disposition position because people
climb to a position and they think
happiness is going live there and I
think you'd be better served trying to
make yourself happy and then worrying
about where you're
going I think your happiness your
emotional well-being working on that
first seems to be a very sensible thing
because it doesn't live down the road it
doesn't live you know you put a million
dollars in the bank it won't it won't
make you less
insecure that kind of scarcity mindset
is kind of poison is that a lesson that
can be learned without going and seeing
the top of the mountain yourself because
there will be a lot of people that could
say Jimmy easy for you to say about Fame
isn't going to fix your problems money
isn't going to fix your problems you've
achieved both well fame fame I think has
replaced heaven in a secular
World Fame is the land of milk and honey
where everything is okay and you're
looked after and it's perfect and I'm
not knocking it I love being famous but
it's not the be all and end all and
actually again you can you can kind of
split test that cuz I can go to a
country where I'm not known not many but
there's a
few you talk about why trajectory is so
important as well and I think that this
ties in here it's all people see isn't
it like people aren't interested in how
you know if you're playing 250 shows a
year like I've been doing that for years
it's not exciting it's not news it's
news when people arrive and they're new
so when something you know
in I think film and TV and comedy and
kind of entertainment it's it's like
it's all about where were they last year
where they this year just
maintaining no one seems to care
although Comics aren't entertainers in
the true sense the true definition of an
Entertainer is if you don't like me I
don't like
me oh that's interesting you've a real
Entertainer you've outsourced your
selfworth to the crowd of course that's
what an Entertainer is and there's I
know guys that are entertaining some
friend said that to me and it was like
oh man that is that is your journey good
luck that's hard comedians desperately
want to be loved but entirely on their
own terms it's a lovely Paradox do you
see that in yourself what what's the the
lesson here
between the desire to make people happy
and laugh and being this uh how do you
say like intrinsic drug dealer yeah and
the fact that you need to be able
to go home at night and put your head on
the pillow without having you know if if
your selfworth is inflated by the crowd
then it can be deflated by their
criticism yeah I mean listen that's the
if if something if something out there
makes you happy losing it is going to
make you sad so it it matters I think
putting on a good show though is about
going do I think it's funny you know
there's certain things that I write and
I go ah feels a bit
doesn't feel quite hasn't got a great
structure to it it's not quite the right
sort of joke for me I'm going to leave
it it's it's not great and then there's
stuff that I like more than the crowd
and it's finding a balance where you go
look I know what you paid to see I know
why you're here and you know the world
ordered a stand-up comedian and I'm
going to honor that I'm going to be as
good at this as I can be and you know
it's kind of a mediation but it's very
much on my terms in ter these are the
jokes that I tell we spoke about that
trajectory thing of a dinner and it's
really interesting
because Andrew Tate someone you might
not have
thought wisdom from this area of the
world would have would have applied but
he says having things isn't fun getting
things is fun and well a stopped a
stopped clock is right twice a
day Ian he says a lot of things he's
bound to get some stuff right he's kind
of an interesting cultural phenomenon
because I think the what do you think
happened with with Tate have you done a
postmortem on his ascendancy to no I
mean the only thing I would say is that
you know young men I feel are in crisis
and uh not that young women aren't in
crisis they are as well I mean young
people generally but it feels like young
men are having a a silent crisis you
know we we talk about certain things and
we don't talk about um other things and
you know young men committing suicide
seems to be a it's a huge problem at the
moment and a lack of purpose and agency
is a huge you know why video games so
popular you know especially with young
men and it's a um a fact simile of
career and purpose and drive and
different levels and there's something
in us there not that men and women are
so very different I always think like
the big difference gender-wise
is men are all taking a
performance-enhancing drug every single
day and that drug is testosterone and
really if you had to talk about what
testosterone does for men it's
risk-taking so and we talk a lot about
all the CEOs all the big CEOs are men
and it's very unfair but also prisons
are full of men because men take
ludicrous risks so I think if you were
going to life hack for I mean I've got a
daughter and the advice I I'll give her
is take more
risks and you can because you're making
it a conscious decision it's not a
hormonal decision then maybe you can
actually do better better because you
can not do the dumb you don't need
to jump from the high board but you can
move to a city where there's more
opportunities taking those risks that
that you know the average man
takes like I kind of look back and it
seemed so easy that I left my
job and became a
comic because I did it the idea that
that was pre-ordained so
stupid such a ludicrous mid-20s Hail
Mary catch of a ah this life's boring
I'm going to go and do something more
fun crazy um so I think that's it's kind
of that's kind of an interesting point
of going the um how do we how do we make
things more equal between men and women
in our society and I think encouraging
greater risk in young women is is a
really
sensible hack cuz that's what that's
what guys have got they're taking crazy
chances
you you you leaving you had a very
comfortable life and a good living and a
good career and you traded it in for
madness for like oh well I'm just going
to be you know is autod dictat you know
it's like you're self-educated you seem
to be you have this kind of thirst for
knowledge you're going yeah well maybe
I'll just do that just doing the thing
that you loved it's one of the reasons
why I had such a problem with the term
it was meant to be so the reason that I
hate
this post Hawk
rationalization of how a bad situation
became a good situation because it was
meant to be in the
end it completely removes all of the
agency that you had overturning that
situation into something that was
good let's say that you lose a leg in a
car crash and you're in a hospital bed
and while you're there you begin
watching history YouTube videos
about ancient Rome and you realize that
you're really interested in it and 10
years later you are now the biggest
ancient Rome historian presenting shows
for your own channel maybe you're on the
BBC you've written books your best you
got only got one leg but it doesn't
matter saying it was meant to be I got
in that car crash for a reason so that I
would spend enough time in a hospital
bed so that I would find the videos
about the Roman Empire so that I could
have this
career ultimately Nets out at taking
away all of the alchemy that you had
yeah that turned this hang on let's do
it in a reverse way you had you got
dealt a really unfortunate card and
managed to there we go that's Blackjack
but the the cards you got dealt are the
cards you got dealt I really like that
thing of like at some point you got to
go with what you got or you're not going
to go so you just you do what you need
to do and like it's interesting now the
uh like the the educational bit of this
the idea that you're going look it's
it's
uh you're educating yourself now to what
end to what purpose well you're making
it easier for for other people down the
line and I'm working on a thing at the
moment where I'm trying to write a um a
language for comedy I'm trying to write
I'm excited for this trying to write a
comedy course a book I'm not quite sure
what it's going to be but the idea of
going I think there's too much Mis ISM
about writing jokes I think even
professionals even some of the goats uh
they kind of write it on stage and they
embody a um a part of their Persona on
stage and they can conjure up these
funny things and there's
Alchemy yeah maybe but actually you can
break it down you can break down what
you're doing there and and it can be
taught the idea that it can't be taught
is to me so incredibly limiting the idea
that comedy can't be taught is like it's
like going well music can't be taught of
course because great musici he saying
that the comedy industry has an
disproportionate number of narcissists
in it Jimmy that would be a surprise how
dare you um yeah I I've got a good line
on narcissism I think I've got a couple
of narcissists in my life so my line is
a narcissist they've got the disease and
you've got the
symptoms pretty much sort of sums it up
doesn't
it hey it's it's an issue if you got one
in your life you know about it um yeah I
think it's really in that thing of going
if it was like music more like music and
people could sort of discover themselves
because really what are the teenage
years about you it's uncomfortable being
a teenager it's uncomfortable like and
and the and we're all you know growing
it doesn't really stop but that idea of
going well who am I if you're the person
you were 10 years ago then you up
if there's no growth in it if you
haven't progressed but it's constantly
asking yourselves kind of the right
questions and and and finding a bit of
humor in that is just makes it just
makes the the journey a little bit
easier doesn't it talking about that
trajectory and
how it's important to think about where
you're going and other people respond to
the rising or falling of your stock in
kind there's an aru but that's that's
character versus reputation so character
is what you know about yourself if you
have a crisis and you're getting
cancelled um your reputation is in the
toilet m but you still know who you are
you know you still you know who you are
and it's that the fundamental question
when you're in the middle of a
cancellation crisis is who are
you oh my Jimmy I'm a standup comedian I
tell edgy jokes oh
okay that's fine this seems appropriate
there's no problem you know who you are
you know what you're about it's it's uh
it's ultimately it's about that kind of
thing just going okay this is this is
fine and also where's your where does
your happiness lie
if it's outside of you if in that true
Entertainer self if you don't love me
then I don't love
me what's it feel like to be canceled or
attempted canceled um it's interesting
like what the term means now I don't
think it's um you call it cancellation I
call it free publicity it's it hasn't
really had I don't know whether it
really exists uh I think it does I think
like there's extreme cases where people
are can no longer work and um are
shunned but hasn't there always been
cancellation it's kind of a new new word
for something that we've always had
there were always people that were um
you know but you've said something
unsayable I mean you've got a right size
it as well the things I've been
cancelled for I told a joke and some
people didn't like
it we got to right size that that's
that's not that bad uh I got cancel once
over tax avoidance not tax evasion you
know the difference no it's about 18
months in prison
but you know that thing of going you
you that was very easy because if you
get cancelled for tax evasion and you
say well I'm I'm going to pay the money
back great we cannot forgive what we
cannot punish there's certain things
that religion does better than a secular
society where we cannot forgive what we
cannot punish so certain crimes like no
laws been broken but ah that guy now
gives me the
ick okay well should he never be allowed
to work again is what did he do what did
he do are there criminal charges what's
going on here what's what's actually
happening and the the reputational
damage and what what could be done
online in a day I mean you can tear
something down pretty
quick and it's uh it it happens every
week it happens to regular people it's
there's a lack of um I suppose because
we live on online and we're not seeing
the whites of each other's eyes um
kindness compassion
forgiveness and very dehumanizing
especially when you get to a certain
level of of
Fame people no longer see very famous
people as people they see them as a
representation of an ideology they're a
conglomeration of ideas sat behind an at
symbol on some form of social media
which is why they're prepared to say
completely reprehensible things that
they wouldn't say to someone who is much
smaller but they would even say much
more reprehensible things to the person
that's much smaller on social media than
they would say to them face to face or
they would even say to them
written a weird thing as well with the
cancellation work the Press would have
you believe press opinion public opinion
and Twitter X are the same thing and
they're all very
different well they want to be the
Arbiters The Gatekeepers of true public
opinion they're not the news aren't in
the news business they're in the
clickbait business clickbait is their
product yeah it's I wonder what news
looks like without that I mean it's you
what was your idea you wanted news
without the without this the video the
sound yeah news without news without
opinion would be I think very
interesting uh there's a there's a um
website at the moment like an app called
the knowledge which gives you all the
day's news and it comes out of about
noon great not first thing have a cup of
tea and relax first but it's like five
sentences tells you all the news you
need to know for the day kind of great
it was an interesting idea of well do
you need all the commentary do you need
to know what they think about
it it's like it's a weird thing there's
a great book called uh by Neil Postman
called amusing ourselves to death and it
came out in 1984 and it's him kind of
railing against they put music music on
the news M it's a show now this that's
that's the beginning of the end for him
they put music on the news and you go
yeah this is It's Entertainment I really
enjoyed that um what's our problem book
by Tim Urban yes I thought was
absolutely fantastic just the idea of
going you know you kind of follow
politics like you're following a a team
you know people are they're just they're
one or the other and they're following
and they're not really watching politics
they're watching the real politicians of
Washington DC where they've picked seven
Great characters to follow yeah like
real housewives you know reality is
boring reality TV is great well the news
is the same it's a great book I really I
would I think that's the book that's
changed the way I think about things
more than anything else the last sort of
12 months really great book you wish
you'd read that 10 years ago before you
went through a bunch of I wish I'd read
it when I was at College I think that's
it's a weird thing where um you know the
stuff I was reading at College was was
sort of nonsense this episode is brought
to you by eight sleep we have decided to
land in the UK during a heat wave and
every Hotel I've stayed in the airon has
broken I thought I'd left Austin so I
could escape the heat turns out I
haven't and the Pod cover from eight
sleep would have been a lifesaver the
Pod cover sits over the top of your
existing mattress just like a normal
mattress topper and actively cools and
heats each different side of the bed
based on yours and your partner sleeping
preferences As you move through sleep
stages it'll change the temperature to
ensure that you stay in deep sleep it is
the biggest game Cher to sleep that I
think I've ever found the Pod cover even
tracks your heart rate variability your
resting heart rate your sleep stages
your sleep consistency it's like having
a wearable built into your bed they also
deliver internationally and if you are
not happy with your pod cover within 90
days for any reason they will give you a
full refund you can get a $150 discount
plus that 90-day money back guarantee by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to 8sleep.com
sodern wisdom that's e e i ghts
sleep.com
slod wisdom but yeah go back you know
regardless of character and reputation
and how much you've tried to bate the
two and Silo them off from each
other there must be a felt sense of fear
there must be a felt sense of ah like
this is happening and largely I'm being
I'm being no it's the worst breakup
you've ever being canceled is the worst
breakup you've ever had because you
you're losing the person you love the
most you're losing you because you've
created and this Cur created and curated
this person this this thing and you have
a reputation which is your your brand is
um sort of a a decentralized opinion on
who you are living in other people's
heads and in a day it's gone or changed
or you know ruined but it's you know
it's all right I think it makes you more
the good to take from it is the empathy
it gives you I always call on the day
what do you think people who aren't
famous don't know about
fame
um I I don't know I mean I I sort of
Stand by that idea it's the land of milk
and honey it's kind of uh a secular
Heaven it's it's kind of my view as it's
the natural state to be because we're
meant to live in tribes right for the
longest time we lived in tribes and
let's say there was 60 80 people in the
tribe and everyone knew everyone and
meeting a stranger was weird what being
famous is like is it's like you live in
one of those tribes but you've got
Alzheimer's so I don't know anyone but
they all know me so people come out it
makes the world a very friendly place so
I go into a coffee shop and get a coffee
and people go you're the guy from the
thing and you immediate there's no small
talk you're into talking about your
career and your life and what's going on
with them and you have a connection with
people and sometimes people don't like
you and those people ignore you and that
it's just a regular
stranger it's great people don't bother
having a negative interaction with you
so they just come up and say something
nice if they're going to something nice
or they don't say anything Al it's like
a selection effect the only people that
do bother coming up to you are the
people that like you the people that
don't like you just ignore you yeah or
they just don't know who the hell I am
you know I think be I I came up I'm one
of the last guys I think to come up and
be famous in in certainly in the UK in
that sense of you know mass
media I'm T
famous and now I think increasingly
we're going to have people that are
famous but in a very limited
way
so you think about musicians there's
very few musicians now that your mom's
heard of right if if your moms heard of
them they are massive right same amount
of records were sold in the 1980s as
today but by it used to be sold by 500
artists now sold by 10 same things
happen with books used to be 500 authors
brought out novels they all do pretty
well now it's like four a year and they
sell incredible numbers but music and
books and if you're into something now
it's seems like it's marrow casting so
it's interesting like the other night we
went out for a drink someone came up and
said oh hey how are you someone came up
to you and was so into it it's like oh
this is my guy this is my guy but it's
probably fewer but much more
intense yeah it's interesting it's it's
just I know we're often told about the
Perils of Fame right that it's reality
warping and that you privacy gets lost
and all the rest of but there's a great
line I remember watching Breaking Bad
and uh my my girl said uh he talking
about it and going well you know power
he power um
corrupts and she went no power
reveals it's like reveals who you really
are like the more it it it is kind of a
revealing thing I think how so I think
you you become you're allowed to be you
know do you live in someone else's world
or do they live in yours
it kind of gets to that you know did we
cover that charm
Charisma thing I've got a real sort of
thing on charm and Charisma being very
different and they're they're conflated
words they sort of mean the same thing
in conversation but I think they're very
different I think um charm
isn't someone you like it's someone you
think would like
you Charisma is you come to me charm is
I come to you
Obama incredibly Charming look at his
speech patterns look at the way he HS
himself he's like he's mediating the
situation it's so damn Charming uh Trump
is charismatic you come to me um one
isn't better than the other particularly
I mean there's a you know example
there's one that I prefer there but as
an individual uh Jennifer Aniston is
charming Angelina Jolie is charismatic
now you both get to Brad Pit that's
the good news but it's a very different
skill set and I think knowing yourself
knowing which one you are is very
valuable which do you think you are all
Charisma zero
charm like zero
charm of course but that's f it sounds
very arrogant I'm all Charisma but you
but that's what I'm working with that's
the thing of like like so someone
charismatic trying to be
Charming SM me
kind of ah falsely disingenuous it does
doesn't come across it doesn't read so
you you got to know know what you're
dealing with know what you're playing
with and there's no judgment
particularly on which one it is but it's
very sort of interesting thinking about
what what you are how people perceive
you I because how you're perceived sorry
but how you're perceived is so important
in our world and it's useful to know
because when people meet me and when
people see me on TV they have a
perception of me now is it true no
there's there's more to me than that you
know I I I'd suffer a bit with the
anxiety I'm very dyslexic not very good
at writing I read quite slowly um none
of that comes across people just go he's
he's all right he's look at him wear in
a sharp suit he's really cutting and
sardonic he's probably unthinking and
what whatever you but knowing that is
really useful you don't have to be that
person but you know it's it's it's good
to know what others think about you I
mean there is a thing about Fame where
if you wear the mask for long enough The
Mask becomes the face yeah you told me
that line the other night that took a
great right good chunk in my 20s to to
realize that um and Al Marcus taught me
that the Persona is incapable of
receiving love it can only receive
praise what he means by that yeah
that's it's very good isn't it
correct yeah that was like a because
this was when I was probably 20 no must
have been 31 I think when he said that
to me for the first time like 2019 so
only you know only four years ago and
I'm still kind
of this big name on campus party
boyish but I'm also not and I'm feeling
this pain so I've got enough distance I
think had I have learned it when I
needed to hear it I wouldn't have had
the perspective to be able to understand
it what isn't that the kind of the thing
with wisdom is it's you could tell any
18-year-old all of this stuff yeah and
it will just different things will
resonate at different times so you can't
read the same book twice you we talked
the other night about Lindy books that's
one of the things I got from this
podcast which I love I got I listening
to this and I was reading Quinton
Tarantino's Cinema speculation I just
want why am I watching new stuff yeah
who gives a about new stuff I want
the best stuff yeah so you go back to
1970 Cinema and books that you read
years ago that meant something to you
and read them again it's that you like
no man steps in the same river twice
because he's not the same it's not the
same river and he's not the same man
yeah yeah the
um so this
like strange idea around the Persona is
incapable of receiving love it can only
receive
praise was really important to me
because I realized that I hadn't
necessarily felt particularly connected
to a lot of the successes in my life I
hadn't felt like they really
got me right and the reason being that
if you are only playing a
role everyone's support and Adoration of
you will feel in some ways Hollow and
shallow because people aren't in love
with you they're applauding the role
that you
play you know we don't love Russell Crow
we love Gladiator we don't love love
Russell he might be listening to you're
his mate so that's different but you
know that yeah that thing of um I
suppose it is the actor it's that we're
playing a role and that role is yeah you
you you kind of don't love someone at
work they're in a chair they're the boss
the whatever they're doing it's not it's
it's a part of them but it's not
authentically them and that's why you
know finding that work life balance
where you go you have a place where you
can totally be your
yourself and be open to
love but also it's interesting the love
thing is interesting to me just as a
sidebar every song for 400 years was
about
God and every song is about
love how do you mean every song's about
love right every song used to be about
God everything used to every every piece
of music pre 1900 was about God
everything and now it's about love I
mean you could make an argument to say
it's the same thing but it's kind it's
just interesting to me that that
culturally that's kind of what we the
gaps well love love as well it's
slightly taken over now the love song
has you know it feels to me like comedy
is having a moment because there it's
reflecting back the world in a very
interesting way it feels like comedy is
having the moment that music maybe had
in the 60s and 70s and Cinema had in the
70s where it really connected with
people people are connecting with
comedians in a way that's I mean listen
I'm I'm part of this but I feel like I'm
I'm in at the ground level like podcasts
are new and we can see podcasts are new
because it's like less than 5 years but
really comedy's only existed in the
current format since I mean who are the
who's the John the Baptist you know
Lenny Bruce and George Carlin and
Richard prior right these guys standing
on stage talking for an hour and people
just came to see them none of that
really happened before there you can
trace it back there's never a first but
you can trace it back to whenever to to
shamanistic um skunk and anany but
really it's a very modern thing standup
comedy this way of it's an American
medium and it
feels incredible to be kind of part of
that as it and it's rising it feels like
it's rising and becoming more important
and I don't know I I don't know who the
the goats are but I kind of I like to
think they're in the future I like to
think the goats
are you know 12 years old now going
through high school like and they're
going to be they're going to grow up
with this language around them oh I came
up with an interesting idea the other
day so I was in Brighton uh giving that
live talk and then James one of my
friends got up on stage and it was
packed 1600 people wall to--all in this
massive Auditorium in Brighton somewhere
and I just wanted to watch his show from
the front so he's done what I'm about to
start doing a lot he sold out Sydney
Opera house he sold out the roundhouse
in London and he sold out the Palladium
so he's done the thing that I'm about to
begin doing with my live show and I was
like I'm going to watch the guy not from
side stage not from backstage I'm going
to observe it I'm going to be
out out there with the peasants so
descend into the muck and the meire and
the feces and the blood sit down during
the interval this guy comes over sits in
front of me and we get talking and he
was uh discussing about how he has
changed the way that he sees himself
about how he has what I called uh
personal growth guilt
so survive a guilt someone goes away to
war their truck gets blown up all of
their friends die he gets stuck in the
back but somehow you survive right you
maybe you're injured maybe you're not
but you get to come home and there's a
very specific type of guilt that's
associated with that which is
his his belief that he should have gone
with his friends right that he should
have been killed along with them I think
this is relatively common amongst
soldiers that come back from
warp he was talking to me about one of
the things that he feels which is like a
personal growth guilt that as he begins
to pull himself away from these beliefs
and insights and Lifestyles that no
longer serve
him he was starting to feel this degree
of guilt for leaving his friends behind
in some regard and I thought that was
very interesting I think that this is
one of the draws that pulls people back
into old habits and old patterns that
they almost don't believe that they are
worthy well it's it's interesting the
move to Austin that you've made because
that thing of like you can't beat your
environment and the idea of I made a
move quite early in life I was 16 and I
moved
schools and it was the first kind of
that that sort of discovery that you are
who you say you are you know I mean
ultimately you'll be judged on what you
do not what you say but it was
interesting to kind of be able to
reinvent myself quite early in life and
go well I'm not going to just mess
around and uh and you know act crazy at
school I'm going to work really hard and
go to Cambridge and really apply myself
and no one thought it was crazy because
I could just turn up in this new place
and go hey I'm you know I'm smart enough
and I'm going to go to Cambridge and
everyone okay
great it's interesting now with the like
Facebook where I think it's becoming
increasingly difficult to distance
yourself from the past you're Tethered
to your past those those those memories
and those photos and those and the
friendships and the connections it's
just difficult to let go there used to
be a high school reunion and you'd meet
someone 15 years after you left school
and go what have you been up
to now you already know it's never going
to happen again right because if you're
interested you're going to know or
you're still connected to them they're
following you you they're they're
they're still part of your life so you
don't get to kind of reinvent yourself
and I think it's quite a healthy thing I
it depends you might have just come out
fully formed and be great but I think
for a lot of us it did involve going
well look this is what I am now this is
what I want to be and I've got a bit of
ambition as opposed to entitlement and
I'm going to work hard to get to there
and sometimes you can be kind of dragged
back by friends and family can be
incredibly supportive but they can also
kind of drag you back there was I had a
weird thing a lot of comics have spoken
about this the idea of um when you start
out you don't really tell your
friends you just go and do it and like
after I know 10 or 20 or 30 gigs or
whatever you tell people you're doing
this new thing but by then you're off
you you've joined the circus one of my
friends has a quote we're not afraid of
failure we're afraid of what other
people will think of us if we
fail yeah which I think is a nice
reframe you know I've never understood
the quote about you're not afraid of
failing you're afraid of what will
happen if you succeed no I'm not not no
I'm not that's what I'm aiming for I'm
afraid of what will happen if I succeed
that's what I'm that's literally what
I'm trying to do but I think we're
afraid of the Judgment of other people
if we do fail or that feels pretty on
the money to me the and you could live a
very you know contained life you scared
of being ridiculed you're scared of
humiliation you're scared of saying I
want to do great things and then not
doing great things but I would argue
saying you want to do great things and
not doing great things is better than
just not doing anything not saying
anything give it a
crack thinking about
that that ability to deal with failure
that ability to sort of face up to
things not going so well and also this
well it's there's different failures
aren't there there's kind of there's
there's recoverable and non-recoverable
failures so you tell a joke and it
doesn't work very recoverable you got
another line straight away locked and
loaded we'll try something else and and
then if they all don't work all the new
lines then you've got the old lines that
you know do work so you sort of you're
okay and then there's there's there's
proper you know kite surfing failures
where you
drown there different failures right
there's different levels of risk and
different tolerance for risk so making
sensible choices on what could you risk
yeah is that seems very sensible George
reminded me I I was lamenting about two
years ago to George about whether or not
George Mack for the people that don't
know the mutual George
friend about whether or not I should
move to Austin and he gave me a frame
that was very instructive which is it's
a reversible
decision yeah you go out there it
doesn't work you come back with your
tail between your legs maybe you're
going to look a little bit silly but
it's it's hardly the end of the world
reversible and irreversible decisions I
think it's such a a lovely I right so if
you're looking at something and you're
saying well should I should I have these
kids that's a big that's a big decision
it's really hard to put them back in
I've heard yeah I mean even and there's
a so there's a real stigma to putting
them up for adoption and as a parent
there'll be days when you go that might
be an angle but you you go that's
irreversible that's forever yeah whereas
other things are you know pretty easy to
reverse so take those
risks and you know even but there's
certain things I think we're set up to
think or the our society set up to tell
us losing your job is the worst thing
that can happen because you find another
job your skill set is the thing that's
interesting add to that there's this
lovely idea
that the skills that you develop along
the way of what you are working toward
in any case so whatever Pursuit it is
that you're going through whatever
challenges are Place placed in front of
you what you are working toward is not
the end goal it is not necessarily even
the outcome because whether it fails or
whether you succeed the skills that you
developed while you were doing this it's
kind of analogous to that um it's Karate
Kid wipe on wipe off it's
also uh analogous to Man's Search for
meaning right Victor Frankle But
ultimately your ability to respond in
any situation is the thing that can
never be taken away from you is that not
disposition is more important than
position yes you know RIT large yes you
go people went through ter that life is
beautiful movie the idea that you go
people went through the worst things in
the world they came out
there's I I I heard an interview with
Esther peral and she said this thing
that really kind of shook me and she was
talking about her parents were in um the
death camps in Germany and she said some
people didn't die and some people lived
and she talked about like people that
have plastic Furniture plastic coverings
on the
furniture they're waiting to live but
they're not living now they they're sort
of it's a really interesting analogy cuz
I think we all know those people that
are saving that room for
special but special every day this is it
this is you know there's a a lovely
frame the original name for this podcast
before I woke up at 3: a.m. with modern
wisdom six years ago was crushing a che
stain and it's a sentence from quite
like it sentence from Tim Ferris and he
talks about you want to design your life
so that the average
Tuesday it's pretty good yeah I
think so because it's you you're like
the the idea of the mountain the idea
that you're aiming towards something
where you will be satisfied there's
always going to be someone that's got it
better than you somehow the idea that
you're you know comparison is the thief
of joy is one of my favorite quotes you
just because you're constantly I've sort
of got a um holistic theory of jealousy
where you you know if you're comparing
yourself to someone else you might look
at their career and go oh my God they're
playing 15 soldout nights at the Oto
Arena oh my God they they must be making
bank incredible no you have to be
jealous of the whole thing take the
whole thing correct you need their wife
their kids their car their house their
life who would you actually swap lives
with like there's like I feel like
there's no one because you go well this
is my I like the adventure I'm on I want
to see how this turns out it's like my
favorite
show yeah I I that I mean that frame
changed an awful lot about jealousy for
me as well you don't know what the inner
texture of Elon Musk or Conor McGregor
or Kim Kardashian's mind is it's that
thing of like especially with people
closer to you than those kind of the the
icons the icons are very useful I think
um to to really admire people that are
doing fabulous things in the world great
but that kind of close when you've got
someone close to you is is it a real
friend or a friend of me so if their
success is your
success if my friend gets a show and
sells out a tour and gets a big break
and he's in a movie if I'm ah I wish it
was me I can't hang out with that
person I can't it's like that would be
that's it's poison but if you if you're
friends with someone their win is your
win yeah like when they get the thing
you're like ah incred even if it's a
thing you really would aspire to and
think was amazing I remember when James
Cordon got the show in the states just
thinking this is so cool this is like
and then you you know you and you can
compare yourself to your friends but you
go yeah but he's he's got charm for days
and he's got skills I don't have what
are you gonna do what's your theory on
kindness well my theory on kindness
would be that we have maybe everyone's
very everyone wants to be
kind and the problem is the marshmallow
test you can have one kindness now or
two kindness
later and we have to I think as a
society as people I think it's the thing
that sort of parenting has kind of
taught me but just life in general like
be kind to yourself be kind to others
later you know and and I think we all
know that thing of like the kind thing
to do now is to go to Gregs and buy some
donuts and smash them great get that
Sugar hit right now and the Kinder thing
to do is to have a salad and feel good
tomorrow and with yourself with others
just delay it delay it do do the kind of
thing it's easy to give in now to whims
and desires but actually if you hold
back it's
better yeah I kindness is kind of like
an unsexy thing it feels almost
like the sort of thing that's very hard
to justify in a capitalistic world one
where everyone's striving we are you
know you got you got a
non-measurable metric y that is
incredibly important you know so we talk
about uh disposition H tough to measure
position oh my God so easy to measure
how you doing how many downloads this
month how many people listening how many
people tweeting what do they say easy
disposition not it's about you how you
feeling yeah like kindness is is uh and
it it comes you're not being
kind it's ultimately it's for you
it's just a nicer way to
live yeah I love this position
disposition hidden observable metric
frame I really think there's something
in there I think they're hidden
observable I I think maybe we could
apply that to
everything you know because what's the
the successful show is it's sold
out does that make it
successful you could fill the room but
can you fill it with laughter you know
it's it's how are you viewing things
like the it's the wrong time scale often
people often think of the show as being
the show tonight all my show is is a
sales pitch for next time that's all it
is all the podcast is today is a
comeback next week there's more of this
it's great and he's chatting to people
and this is the kind of conversation he
has
great it's just doing more it's process
driven not outcomes driven do you know
what good heart's law is good heart's
law good heart's law it sounds like a
sequence to a
movie it's kind of the people that
brought you how'd you let them Apple
kind of kind of like Parkinson's law so
Parkinson's law says that work expands
to fill the time given for it okay
fundamentally
the it's the justification for time
blocking in productivity strategy it's
why you completed your University
assignments the night before they were
duing or sometimes if you were me
throughout the entire night before they
were do in yeah what's that great line
the I think it's Dickens said I would I
would have written you a shorter letter
but I didn't didn't have the
time so that's Parkinson's law good
heart's law says when a measure becomes
an outcome it ceases to be a good
measure so when it's the over Reliance
on dashboards for everything right yeah
if I was to optimize on the podcast for
plays right that's a measure plays are a
measure of the success of the podcast if
I begin to use that measure as an
outcome it no longer is a good measure
because it doesn't measure the thing
that it's supposed to measure right I
could get lots and lots of email
addresses by posting all over the
Internet sign up to my mailing list and
every single person that signs up will
get ,000 right people will then sign up
and I won't give him ,000 pounds because
I'm not going to do that so the metric
of acquire as many email addresses as I
can good did that yeah but the actual
outcome I wanted was accumulate lots of
people on a maing list who actually want
to hear from me who trust in me and are
going to click on links and are going to
care about what I've got to say like
that's the actual outcome can I ask
about that like sidebar but the I like
the email that you sent I I'd rather you
said it you want me to dictate it don't
I'd rather that was a mini podcast that
came at the beginning of the show here's
what I've been thinking about I'd rather
it was just a because it's often that
thing if you go I'm listening to it I I
kind of
uh you know I like it I like those
things those thoughts but for me it's
the the medium is the message and for
you it seems to be podcasts are and I
think actually if you put those together
I think maybe that's the
book that's it's it's taking these
little things so you're you're sort of
the process is you're writing it as you
kind of go along and you're taking those
those things that really resonate with
people and I don't disagree I mean it's
it's the thing that fires me up the most
to do this like whatever we want to call
it bro philosophy like common guy life
Insight stuff I really like it I like
bringing those two things together but
have you seen you know Jonathan height
right hate height uh he's writing his
next book in public it's really
interesting way he the coddling of the
American mind that guy yeah that's a
great book yeah fantastic and then he he
wrote this uh great essay for the
Washington Post I think called the Tower
of Babel and it's kind of a development
on from where he was coddling of the
American mind he's s big into this
antisocial media thing he's concerned
about what it's doing to especially
young girls sense of self and anxiety
and so on and so forth however what he's
doing on his maybe substack maybe
something else he's writing the book
chapter by chapter publishing it maybe
just to paying members or maybe for free
to everybody they just getting feedback
on getting feedback and iterating so he
will have released every single chapter
of his book's first draft for largely
free over the space of a year or 18
months it's a great idea it's kind of
the wisdom of crowns if you think about
music as well like the great bands often
go out and play it first before they
finish the album they go and play it and
see what the reaction is it's it's
interesting like you know it's I suppose
the not looking behind the Wizard's
curtain but like with great stand-up
comedians like when you see Chris Rock
do an hour you go yeah well he he wrote
probably 2,000 jokes in order to do
those 70 that worked brilliantly and in
order to do those he put how much time
in and he you know you want to road test
it you don't want to do all new
material I came up with an idea which is
similar to something you talk about a
lot you call it the quarter life crisis
and I called it the Mano
pause pause is nice yeah it's nice but
it's the it's it's early right it's that
mid 20s I think it's when you start to
make your first decision in life so
pretty much on a treadmill if you think
about it from from the age of five you
go into the education system and it was
great when we had an Empire because we
needed people that went through the
education system to go and run the
Empire that was what it was for that's
the what the education system in Britain
that's kind of gone out to the Western
world was for now not so much so this
idea that it's exams at all these stages
and you know what the metric is you know
what the measurable is so the measurable
isn't what you found now which is the
joy of learning the joy of reading the
joy of ideas
that's what school should be about but
it isn't it's about passing exams and
get to did I choose to stay on and do
aels no no the obvious thing to do after
you're 16 you do stay on and that
everyone goes to University I mean
everyone goes to University now and you
go to the best one you can so to
Cambridge and then after Cambridge what
do you do well everyone's getting a job
now they've got to get a job who do I
get a job with well the biggest blue
chip company I can find yay so you get a
job and then you kind of turn around
what a year two years depending on how
bright you are I'm not that bright about
two years in I kind of went the am
I doing you that great quote of every
man's got two lives and the second
begins when he realizes he's only got
one and that so you get off the
treadmill and go what and then it's very
it's there's a book called um what color
is your parachute which I read at the
time which is kind of a asking questions
that lead you to that what are you going
to do there's loads of that kind of self
stuff on the internet now which is I
always think it's like uh it's
horoscopes for people with a
levels you know the kind of whether it's
Mya's Brig or whatever but those are
fascinating because you kind of go why
do people like horoscopes I just want to
read about myself yeah just yeah I'm I'm
a little bit self-obsessed and
narcisstic but doing those
person my Edge what's the thing that I
do that I find easy that other people
find difficult and there's a little bit
of gold there and I could pursue that
that would be a that would be a purpose
that would be something that's a true
north and um is it uh tiic and anti-ck
you pronounced it differently to me I
don't telic and exoic yeah I've only
ever seen it written down uh it's weird
I kind of like that when you don't know
yeah uh but the but that idea of like
tasks Without End will make you happy
tasks with an end can be a bit
depressing if you get to the end of a
project
and it's done huh finite in infinite
games isn't it yeah yeah I uh that
manopause thing it came about I first
called it the fitness menopause so I
noticed around about
20 27 26 27 that I
was all of the training strategies that
I'd been relying on like Push Pull legs
and bro split and I was looked fantastic
but kind of got out of breath going up a
set of stairs and I couldn't bend over
and touch my toes all the rest of it so
what I realized was I I probably should
try and pivot my training and I saw it
with a lot of my friends a lot of the
guys that are listening to this podcast
will feel this as well the training
protocol that you followed especially if
it's a bro split through your 20s you
get toward the end of your 20s and I'm
like ah am I steeping in my own Neurosis
powered by 500 milligrams of caffeine
looking at myself in the mirror I'm kind
of done with this and then people pivot
and they start doing yoga or they do
Brazilian jiu-jitsu or they do
kickboxing and they go and try CrossFit
they do whatever and I noticed that
first but it was actually the lead
measure of a whole bunch of other
changes which was the things that I
thought served
me in my
20s weren't
self-authored the things that I thought
I wanted and the things that I wanted to
want had diverged I didn't want the
things that I wanted right I actually
when I looked sufficiently
deep well is that I mean the what do you
want to want as a question is I mean
that should be the name of the book it's
so good it's so good but that
thing of I didn't want what I wanted is
dopamine that's just dopamine it's the
idea of going no the chase was the thing
the chase was your reward so when you go
shopping and you buy the the watch the
car the whatever the the trinket is that
you thought you wanted that represented
something and then you get it and it's a
bit blah it's that how many times do you
have to do that before you realize okay
trinkets aren't for me there's nothing
in
trinkets you're you're the ambition
should be emotions can I spin you a yarn
about the pineapple the pineapple yes
not much you can tell me about
pineapples but yeah sure very important
fruit let me show you that you're wrong
so 1492 Christopher Columbus lands on
the island of
Guadalupe and for the first time ever
Western person discovers the pineapple
kind of looks like a royal fruit right
it's got little little Crown true on its
head and he describes in his journal
eating it if you've never had a
pineapple before and you hadn't had
other fruits that were sort of created
outside of the UK stuff like apples and
stuff the pineapple is overpowered as
like it's a Superfruit right it's
so sweet and juicy nice anyway describes
it brings it back right uh Prince or
King Ferdinand II of Aragon king of
Spain I think he takes it back to First
and they take a literally
boatload take all of these ones back one
isn't rotten when he brings it back it
gets given to the king so the first
pineapple that's ever eaten by somebody
who's a Westerner is it's done in a very
sort of ceremonial fashion this myth
about the pineapple propagates and after
a little while trade begins to improve a
little bit the pineapple becomes one of
the most ostentatious displays of wealth
that anybody in the British aristocracy
can rely on for about 300 years you know
you know on the Strand in London is
there a pineapple used to be able to
rent pineapples $8,000 oh £8,000 is the
equivalent of what it would cost but
people would rent them for dinner
parties they would parade them round
look yeah look at this and they would
have statues out front of the estate as
if to say you know what the gag is on
the Statue so the pineapple um I'll go
toe to do on pineapples so on Stately
homes they'll often have a stone
pineapple out the front and it's a
gag so the gag is when sailors would
come back from the West Indies they'd
often bring a pineapple M and they would
put the pineapple in the window the
girls would put the pineapple and the
pineapple kind of meant no gentleman
callers my husband's home uh and he's a
sailor and that gag that gag has been
lost in the in the M but the the
aristocracy put a pineapple at the front
of their house it kind it was kind of a
joke it was a reference to that but the
joke got lost so that's interesting I
didn't know that you're teaching me
things about pineapples here pineapples
once but the my friend wrote a book
about Pineapples uh but that thing in
the Strand you could yeah you could rent
pineapples and you would show them off
and then and then suddenly that thing
that they was the most lorded special
thing ain't nothing and see where I'm
going you look at it now and you go
what's the thing there's nothing you can
buy in a shopping mall that you will
give a about in 10
years nothing there's nothing for you
there fast forward do something for you
in 5 years time don't buy the thing you
don't need it so that story about the
pineapple and its subsequent demise when
the French invent green houses and you
can grow fruits from much more tropical
climates where we are uh related to a
lesson that Rogan taught me when I went
on his show last year and I called it
Rogan's value difficulty conflation look
at the car he's driving look at the
watch he's wearing look at the girl he's
with that's unattainable to many people
so it seems like it's valuable but then
you ained it and then you realized oh
this isn't valuable this is just
difficult to get and there's a
difference there's a big difference
what's valuable is something that
fulfills you intellectually emotionally
spiritually and lovingly most smart
people realize that there is value in
stepping outside of their comfort that
on the other side of discomfort is
something valuable we're told that
worthwhile things are difficult to
attain because if they weren't difficult
to attain they wouldn't be worthwhile
this is how non-valuable but difficult
things get slipped into our design
without us noticing attaining something
worthwhile is often going to be
difficult but just because it's
difficult doesn't mean it's worthwhile
we use the challenge as a proxy for
virtue or value or alignment or
Integrity there's some signaling going
on here too difficult things by Design
will be attained by a small number of
people which makes them desirable simply
because it's an easy way to stand out
from the crowd but just because it's
difficult to attain does not mean that
it's valuable I mean that's great the
only thing I would take issue with there
is most smart people realize
no no they don't and I can prove
it
Yachts
Yachts someone's bought a yacht
someone's buying a yacht today
Yachts great there's a level at which
people are just maybe okay if you don't
enjoy a conversation with a friend
you're not going to enjoy a
yacht what do you think you're doing on
the
yacht yeah well I mean that nval quote
if you can't be happy with a coffee you
won't be happy on a yacht yeah is it's
perfect right yeah it's perfect it
because you you go that is it's so true
how early in life can you know that how
what age do you have to be before you
can go ah you're chasing rainbows this
is there's nothing that external stuff
isn't going to bring you the thing that
you want but how much of a quest you
need to go
on before you can sort of
realize that but that's the you know
that's been a repeating theme throughout
today about you can bestow all of these
insights but the 18-year-old version of
me wouldn't have listened to this in any
case and it seems like even if someone
shows you a photo of the top of the
mountain this is what it looks like this
was the route that I took to get there
here were the pitfalls that you should
avoid
ultimately it takes a very singular
person to be able to learn from the
mistakes of others rather than the
mistakes of Who had who had that line
about it was climbing Everest or
whatever and someone someone Cho it up
there it wasn't Everest it was another
Mountain but like they didn't climb up
they got a chopper up took some photos
and
went it's a nothing
experience who cares might as well just
get you can get sent some photos like
there's nothing in that like doing that
wanted to do that pilgrimage but I
thought I'll do it real quick so I did
it on a jet ski it's not anything if if
you're if you're not not willing to take
the journey yourself it's you got
nothing it's interesting that thing of
the manopause that you had 26 27 that LE
leaks to links to the um uh the
developmental kind of biology of the
when's the brain finished yeah it's
interesting your brain was just finished
yeah what do I think about 25 for guys
is it 24 for women it's like but it's
that old that we're fully integrated
ready to
go and and at that age miraculously
about 12 months in you went well this is
nonsense I got to do something else yeah
yeah I I see it I see it in a lot of
people um we spoke the other night about
inner critics what you think the
relationship that we should have with
our inner
critic I mean I think it's it's
interesting Walt Disney had three
different rooms so he had a room to be
creative right just come up with ideas
no bad ideas great other than some of
the anti-Semitism anyway so he's got his
ideas room and then he's got his um he's
got his management room well how how do
we make those room how do we make those
ideas happen how are we going to make
that stuff happen and then you had
another room for
criticism and I think we should sort of
think about the inner critic like that
the idea of going if you're trying to do
something creative don't let the critic
in too
soon wait until you've had the whole
idea wait until you've let the
management get involved a little bit
wait until you've tried to write the
whole joke and come at it from from a
few different angles and tried it twice
before you critic you criticize it and
Outsourcing your critic I think is is
smart I mean comedy does it with the
audience really they make the decision
as to what the show is they do the
editing for
me do you got a much better relationship
with failure with that it it engenders a
much better relationship with failure
yeah because it's not identity level
yeah the jokes of the bullets I'm the
gun like easy come easy go yeah so you
let go of it you know but also when
you're doing something creative you got
to kill a lot of
babies they're all very precious to you
and you think they're fa there a
fabulous little idea and it's nothing
audience just stared at you okay all TR
the next one yeah that was swinging a
Miss yeah great but that isn't that kind
of a nice attitude for it's hard though
when you've made something that's you if
it's a movie or a a book that you've
worked on for years but that super smart
uh guy trying every chapter as he goes
along that's super smart yeah low stakes
low pressure creativity is something I
wonder whether it's played into by this
sort of concretizing of everything that
you've ever
said throughout all of time being there
that it doesn't feel like the ephemeral
can be ephemeral anymore you can't just
blast it out it's iPhones at a comedy
show are kind of the en enemy of
creativity censorship is not a problem
in
comedy self-censorship is a huge problem
people not saying the unsayable risky
thing that could be the funniest
because they're worried well if
that's taken out of context what if
people don't understand I mean like why
do people like comedy there's a lot of
nuance in comedy isn't there there's no
Nuance in the modern world there's no
Nuance in in you know what's reported in
the media it's all a weird newsp and
then in comedy like you can say the
craziest and people know it's not
yeah there's no hate in his did fun did
you see uh Rosanne get popped for that
little bit she did with theovon she was
making a joke about the Jews and she
basically said that not enough of them
were she she was it was the most
probably the most
egregious clipping of a bit Yeah seen I
didn't see it so I can't really comment
but the idea of like the bad faith
argument that journalists make of going
I know it's a joke
it was in a comedy show at a comedy club
that's the context it was a joke and
they go okay well let's report it as if
it was a statement that was made ladies
and gentlemen can I get your attention I
to make a comment here about no no one
said
that she'd made a bunch
of
obviously sarcastic very overthe
toop opposite statements it was like and
the pigs will fly and the sky is green
and the D D D D D basically for for ages
and ages and ages and ages and ages and
then at the very end said like and not
in your Jews summ summ summing it was
part of it was an Ever escalating
statement about the Ridiculousness of
some of the claims that were being made
with some some something and they just
took the bit at the end yeah and I was
like come on you know I'm all for saying
you know this needs to be able to stand
up on its own
like things can be taken in a little bit
of isolation but not that much
isolation yeah it is interesting though
isn't it the idea of you go well you
could take anything out of context and
someone's going to be upset as well also
you've got how much access to people now
everyone's got to say it used to be that
would have been an eye roll and a touch
from someone right someone said that not
for me thank you won't be buying a
ticket I won't go and now it's the the
idea of saying I don't like that seems
very reasonable to me no one should have
access to that seems like a different
thing so you know the free speech thing
is you go well until we find a better
system we have to have free speech what
about Chinese system that's a good
system yeah I mean I mean that's the
world we could be living in you know
where I mean it's you know Charlie Brook
is a mate of mine and that those kind of
black mirrors where people are getting
so social points and then it's happened
I it's happening right now it's
unbelievable it's
like 1984 is happening right now you
know that they've got got in China Gate
analysis that can work out even face
covered wearing clothes can work out who
someone is with about 90% plus accuracy
just from the way that they walk so
hiding your face hiding everything
dressing differently doing whatever
isn't sufficient to protect you now
they've fingerprinted your uh yeah
movement it's interesting that thing of
like the micro the macro so you can't
move
privately but I think maybe with social
media now you can't think
privately because everything's um it
becomes slightly
performative and there's no
boredom you're constantly stimulated I
think we're slightly over stimulated as
a society like being bored is really
good for creativity being a bit bored
and a bit like listless you know
sometimes I look even now it happens but
it used to happen more previously at how
many things I'll be doing at once so
I'll be replying to an email whilst I'm
waiting for the cattle to boil I'll be
setting the dishwasher away whilst
listening to a podcast at two times
speed and I'll be waiting for somebody
I'm like I've got like I I'm literally
waiting for five things to happen while
doing three that's the modern condition
though isn't it that you're you're so uh
addicted to
activity doing something and feeling
like you're being productive and
actually just letting s kind of s having
some time just to think it's the Charlie
Munga thing isn't it the idea of waiting
and just having time just to think and
do
nothing read
stuff read what's your the you've got a
theory on the Chinese what's your theory
about the Chinese my theory on the CH
Chinese the same Theory as uh um well my
theory on the Chinese we don't need to
worry there are covers ban the Rolling
Stones are not worried about the bootleg
Rolling Stones right because they're the
Rolling Stones they're coming up with
this and playing it and someone's
doing a cover version China at the
moment is a is a is a covers band and
there's something there's some sweet
Source in our system where Innovation is
created and we're coming up with stuff
and you look at the five biggest
companies in the world and they're all
tech companies that came up in the last
10 years 15 years whatever it is it's
incredible The Innovation that we have
you don't need to to worry about it it's
like AI I'm not worried about AI
it's artificial intelligence as soon as
it's artificial
Consciousness great I'll be concerned
that all can can computers write jokes
yeah when they start laughing at jokes
that's that's when there'll be a problem
there was this I think it was George
that taught me this one as well um a
really good measure of AI will be I
think it's called stairway wit you heard
of this stairway wit stairway wit or
stairwell wit so um Spirit discal the
French term for you know when you have a
dinner with someone and you you're
walking down the stairs from the
restaurant and you think I wish I'd said
that correct is that the yes yes what's
what's that called Spirit discal I'm
going to guess that means the spirit of
the
staircase yeah there you go there you go
the French they've always going to make
everything so much more I think it's
because the restaurants were often on
the floor Upper Floor and you walk down
the steps that's cool so that was their
it's a French think and the French are
like genetically not very funny so
presumably yeah they are who's funny you
said that um Gad there's a guy called
Gad it's very funny um there's a girl
called um oh what she called come back
to me in one second
um
oh I'm blanking on her name because the
French used to dat uh blanch gardan is I
watched it that's a French name
I don't speak French I watched it in
French with subtitles blanch Gan special
blew my mind really so
maybe spoken too soon no this incredible
funny funny people everywhere but that
um it's weird the uh the stairs thing
this is very on a tangent but it's
interesting let's talk about the
environment
again okay so are you aware of New York
at the uh turn of the century okay so
New York turn of the century incredibly
loud every street is cobbled seen gangs
in New York you get the visual right
every stre is cobbled horse and carts
everywhere and people on Horseback right
cuz you got to get around the horse
is yay deep okay uh when horses die they
die in the street and they have to wait
for them to atropy slightly before they
cut them up
manually and cut them off so you know
that kind of Trope about you've heard
about smelling salts and people talk
about it's fetch the smelling salts it's
from that
era London was the same but New York had
it really bad because it's an island so
you know there the steps going up to the
Brownstones the steps going up to the
Brownstone buildings with a little metal
scraper and that was so you could walk
out of the and scrape it off your
feet before you went into the
house covered in the whole of New
York was covered in and they they
had a law and they wrote a law about it
and then another law and then they
brought in a tax and then they brought
in another tax and another law and
another law or that nothing changed it
was covered in and it smelled awful
and it was
hell and then Henry Ford came along
and horses went
from a million horses to six of them now
in Central Park taking tourists around
and no more horeshit problem and I kind
of I kind of think things can change
very
quickly I mean maybe that's a
ludicrously optimistic view of the world
because the biggest industry in the
world in 1902 was
whaling you're kidding no biggest
industry in the world was wailing
because they would need the blubber and
the oil for lamps the oil was everything
right you know what's a resource is a
really interesting question so you go
that that oil from Wales was a resource
and we didn't wipe out the Wales but we
came as close as you'd ever want to get
and then suddenly a bit of tech came
along and and saved them yeah um I mean
it's it's it's the it's kind of a little
bit tropy but one of the best ways to
ensure that people pivot from a behavior
that they do to a behavior that you want
is to make the behavior that you want
more attractive than the behavior that
they do it's the way that Elon Musk
managed to do what the Prius never did
because he made an electric car that was
cooler than a normal car yeah it's uh
yeah it's interesting that thing of like
whenever you look at Society wherever
you're calling from in this moment we
imagine it's finished we imagine this is
the last iteration of humanity all the
technology up to now that's but that's
pretty much it right we're never going
to get Beyond this this right because
it's never going to computers don't get
better than this phones don't get better
than this we don't have better medicine
than we do today this is it we've
reached the Pinnacle right look around
it's never going to get any better we
somehow can never factor in that's never
ever been the
case but we can't in our heads we can't
get our head around the idea things are
going to get
better tell you what else I loved I
learned this term from a uh a historian
of exist potential risk so I'm big into
X risk and and and trying to avoid it
and learning about personally you're
trying to avoid it cuz that's kind of
doesn't work that way yeah it's
difficult to do yeah uh but I don't want
Humanity to go extinct and I think that
our someone write that down that's a
lovely thought efforts are placed in the
wrong direction they're placed in the
wrong place which is you know beyond
Lor's kind of like fundamentally his
thesis within human flourishing but I
think he could even spread it out
further than that this is William MLL
from the future of humanities Institute
this is Nick Bostrom and Toby odds
workor again from Oxford
uh 30,000 foot view all of our attention
is currently paid or the vast majority
of our attention in terms of existential
risks are paid on things that are not
existential risks There is almost 0%
chance that the next Thousand Years
humanity is going to be wiped out by
climate change but well I I I don't know
because I think a like what what do you
consider climate change CU you know the
super volcano know mhm if that goes that
could you know you familiar with this uh
the theory of uh I think it's called
bookas bedos blanket you ever heard of
this so it's the idea that if you put um
coal in Coal Fired you know uh power
plants into the atmosphere it's it
causes warming it's terrible we should
stop doing it but if you go high enough
with the chimney into the stratosphere
uh if you go high enough it those
particles reflect light and it cools the
Earth the Stratos the stratosphere
reflects light from the sun the sun's
the only thing heating us we cool down
it's a thermostat on the globe wow and
here's the thing here's the kicker it's
been
tried okay when katoa went off such a
huge volcano it put so much Ash into the
upper atmosphere the Earth cooled by I
think I think it was 2 degre I could be
wrong about the amount and there was no
summer in Europe the next year wow so
it's it's kind of we know we could do it
but I mean the amount of how bad does it
need to get before we do that how bad
does it need to get before we harness
the atom you know the the idea that you
go all of the existential risk of
nuclear power is there because we have
weapons but we're not really using the
power as much as we could be yeah and
that seems to be the why not take that
and people go what about safety well
okay we'll put some more safety on it
then yeah the the conversation around X
risk is what's called anthropogenic risk
so our risk human created versus natural
risk super volcanoes
asteroids Godzilla coming up from
underneath the ocean I mean the idea is
a super volcano goes off as an asteroid
lands on it plugs the hole perfect yeah
we might get
lucky we might get lucky let's just
let's try and focus on that let's try
and focus on that's your positivity
coming in again so so what's the other
ones what's the other big existential
risks so the most likely one is AI right
and this book The the original
conception by Toby Orin the precipice
was written probably about six years ago
maybe maybe four years ago so this is
before chat GPT and I'm going to guess
that he would have increased his his uh
estim AI is going to wipe us AI it's the
most likely so he says that there's
pathogens AI uh so natural pandemics
engineered pandemics AI nanotechnology
they're the big movers right we all get
turned into Grey Goo we have unaligned
ai we have an engineered pandemic from
some bastard in the lab or some gain of
function research that accidentally gets
released or we have a natural pandemic
that everybody now the reason
there very specific way that there's
wording put for existential risk it's
total unrecoverable collapse yeah right
when sorry when do I plug my show in
this because I feel like people need to
buy tickets for a comedy show at this
point in this point in the conversation
like I mean you watch more of this
but this is this is bad right so
unrecoverable yeah permanent sorry not
total permanent unrecoverable collapse
and the problem with almost everything
including nuclear weapons you'll notice
that nuclear weapons weren't in there
nuclear weapons all of them go off at
the same time it's catastrophic it's
hell on Earth but it's not permanent
unrecoverable collapse the difference
between there's a really great thought
experiment where
what is the greater difference between
0% and 99% of humanity being killed or
between 99% and 100% being killed and
when you look at it with a long-termism
lens it's the 99 to 100 well also you're
looking at the wrong
thing you you've read the selfish Gene
you're looking at Humanity you should be
looking at DNA that's I mean listen
we're just we're just Meat Puppets
getting the stuff to the Future right
that's ay L ay lob had this idea I had
him on this dude who's looking he's
going to fire a light sail fire a laser
from the earth at a light sail and try
and Propel a craft up to about 20% the
speed of light send it towards uh Alpha
centor that's going to happen within the
next decade something like that and the
message is going to read it's just
a very thin piece of like reflective
foil I think I don't know how much does
it say help maybe send help SOS um but I
asked him do you ever think that we'll
send generation ships to other planets
do you ever think that we will have you
know all the SS um bukaki yeah well
I don't know I mean presumably the SS
inbred is going to be the name of the
ship yeah maybe it's the yeah all aboard
the SS
Norfolk they get on board
intergenerationally marrying what yeah
it's yeah his argument is the best your
half of the ship can't meet that half of
the ship for 20 Generations or we're all
yeah yeah yeah yeah his argument
is that you get to um the best way would
be desktop DNA synthesizer attached to
one of these ships keep everything
Frozen get it over there drop it down
artificial
WBS away you go is this not okay your
worry about this is not we talked about
anxiety earlier right and anxiety if you
were going to sum it up is it's a
Restless mind and you're problem solving
for the future
because there's not enough going on now
I would argue there's quite a lot going
on now that we could nail here and that
as a byproduct of that like like the
idea of intergenerational ships
traveling at light
speed ah I don't think it gets us
anywhere I think I'd be with Eric
Weinstein on like a new physics might be
the thing that gets us somewhere and if
you think about where we were isn't
there some weird fact about from the
right Brothers to um landing on the moon
is is it 67 years or something yeah we
we've done it before although you know
how NASA did it someone told me this
recently talking about NASA went until
they put a man on the moon yeah
absolutely they put a man on the moon
how did they do
it moment when we know what the budget
was
unlimited they had an unlimited budget
you can have anything you want and any
one you
want I'll put a man on the moon with
that I
mean honestly interesting how tough
could it be unlimited uh you can have
anyone you want and it can cost anything
you want but it can't take as long as
you want as well so remember we learned
about Parkinson's law just before the
task will expand to fill the time given
for it that was not it was before dot
dot dot before the Russians yeah well it
was the that thing of like you don't
there's a great lawn Michaels quote
about Saturday Night Live but he says
the show doesn't start at 11: on a
Saturday cuz it's ready it's it goes on
because it's 11 o' on a
Saturday sometimes you got to go with
what you got right yeah the before the
Russians think of like what did we you
know Wars are great apart from war if
you could take the war bit out of War
like The Innovation that comes of it
because in those desperate times and now
you know I don't know what's going on
with the you know we're fighting these
proxy wars and the the human suffering
and the devastation you kind and for
what I can't see what happens I don't
know man I mean it's there is a degree
to which there's an
ever increasing velocity of the Spiral
of ping ponging between this thing and
the next thing and what's it going to be
and I understand why people feel
overwhelmed I I I get it too but I don't
know the last few years I've since being
around more smart people and more
hopeful
people I just I've got faith for some
reason that everything is going to be
fine I I listen that thing that we were
talking about earlier about like what's
your belief is that the truth doesn't
matter it's a useful belief very useful
belief to think that things will be okay
and that maybe in some small part way uh
some small way we could play a part in
that that would that would be huge you
know so that thing of going what what
are you going to do well if you have an
aptitude for for physics go and study
Physics or chemistry or math whatever
you're doing do more of
that you spoke earlier on about your
kids and you said about how we we
mentioned the other night I think you
identified the difference between life
on easy mode or life with low Stak this
is yeah so this was my theory on life
was I have a partner I've been with for
many many years and we get on
great and it struck me that not having
kids was like we didn't want kids and it
was living life on with a cheat on the
video game super this is super
easy why was it easy because the the
what I didn't realize you think you have
skin in the game but you don't have skin
in the game until you have kids because
it's it's a medical procedure where your
heart now lives outside your body that's
what it is you know so you go now you
you feel invested in the future and and
and and you you're more worried wor
you're worry more about your mortality
now you've got
kids because it's yeah what's the worst
that could happen you could die well now
it's much
worse there might be a saying goodbye so
I think it was I thought I was living
life on easy settings and actually I was
playing a very low stakes table and now
I feel like I'm playing in a higher
Stakes table and it's it's very joyful
is it also terrifying though you've got
this heart that lives outside of your
body yeah I think so I think I spend a
lot of time with the
um you know thinking about what could
what could happen and and anxiety you
know if I let myself there's kind of a
um there's a there's a tendency towards
counterfactuals and what what could
happen what if he what if he walks into
the road what if something awful happens
but I read that um uh the codling of the
American mind book and it really kind of
made me think yeah childhood is about
experimentation and risk and letting
kids be kids let them let them do their
thing yeah I it's interesting to think
about the
protective motivation that a lot of
people have myself included you know you
hear about this sound of Freedom film
that just came out recently and I had
one of the guys that was a part of it on
the show pleas tell me about these kids
that are being trafficked and you know
it's like a like visceral
compulsion that you have to make it stop
and to help
I didn't see I didn't see the the movie
but is that how he made his money
no yeah ruined his business God you got
really interesting guests on this show
his business and
uh there's something about that you know
this sort of desire to protect but for
me it's largely abstract right like I
know that it's an ethical thing to
protect a child right it's the same for
me it's the exact same for me as
thinking about a sister right
incest aversion for me is not an emotion
that I
have I don't I don't feel incest
aversion because your sister's fat
because I'm an only child oh right that
too yeah sure just with you but
the uh the so when people talk about
like in I can make like would you
your sister jokes all day long yeah
because for me it doesn't TR there's
nothing visceral I understand I
understand and I'm sure that if I had a
sister I wouldn't him m
but right the bare minimum um yeah okay
and it's the same I think a little bit
with this and I'm interested to work
because you you've got a good example of
long enough life without kids to then
have them do you is there like a global
cartel of parents that become extra
protective and more invested in the
well-being of all children I always
found it very annoying preh having kids
that like that kind you wouldn't
understand you gots yeah you do you're a
person in the world you don't change
entirely when you have kids it's a it's
a lovely to do and I think it um I think
there's it's kind of a final it feels
like it's another bit of growing up it's
another bit of growth where you kind of
go oh you know especially in my business
where you are a bit self-obsessed at
Show Business you go well there's
someone else to worry about now don't
you know and it's it's fun for me and I
kind of you know because you're kind of
in play mode with kids and my job is
kind of play mode it's good to Anchor
myself in that it's um yeah it's it's
joyful it really is joyful it's lovely I
mean there's a weird thing of like you
know it's it's I think parents kind of
can
sometimes they're either going you
desperately you've got to have kids oh
my God it's ruined my life and it's you
can find people in both camps and I
think again it's it's uh it's this
position they're all parents there's
some very happy parents and some not
very happy Parents and I think it's
about
expectations what did you think it was
going to be like now what's happiness
its expectations exceeded then why is
New Year's terrible why are birthdays
boring because you expecting it's going
to be the best night ever and then it
was okay or even if it is the best night
ever you go yeah well I was expecting
that and somehow crushing a Tuesday
sometimes having a great time when it
was unexpected is the most joyful thing
yeah so having kids what what do you
what do you think it was going to be
like how do you think it was going to be
so think it's going to be terrible not
even think it's going to be terrible
just like being realistic about it going
you it's going to be it's going to be
this lovely moments and you're very
present with I don't really I always
want to meditate and I never really find
the time to meditate and I'm I think I'm
terrible at it but I'm good at going on
walks and I'm good at playing with kids
you when you're with a kid playing with
a kid you're you're in the moment you're
just there there's nothing else it's
lovely yeah I
uh I think that there's a few decisions
that you can make in life Downstream
from them there it's an entire lifestyle
change so buying a dog would be one
right that especially because dogs are
usually a precursor to kids in some form
yeah F
babies and downstream from that you have
something else that you're responsible
for you need to get up at a time it
needs to be fed and watered and walked
yeah it's often my thing of the cure for
depressed friends is to encourage them
to get a dog oh hell yeah because you
might not need to get out of bed till
noon but the dog needs to poop so yeah
you you got to get up and out and put
something on and go to the shop and buy
some food and taken care of someone else
it's often like if you're having a
really tough time finding someone who's
worse off and calling them and checking
in is really valuable it's odd but it
really helps you know it's that thing of
you know if you're going through
something reach out and try and help
someone and it just puts you in a
different position with with the you
know your
problem
one trend that I see amongst some of my
friends who
are more resilient or capable is
sometimes
they allow themselves to be relied on
and allow themselves to serve others and
a lot of the time end up not being
served themselves so it's that uh
Guardian rather than dependent Dynamic
continues to just get flipped with them
always being the person that's the one
that internal critic the idea that you
sometimes the circle of compassion
you're not in the circle it's everyone
else around you and then you're not in
it and you you know you meet a lot of
people that aren't very good to
themselves very generous with everyone
else and then they're not very good to
themselves that's a strange I don't know
what's going on there but it's it's seem
is that something you ever encountered
no I'm I'm pretty good to myself I think
no it's not really a that's it's
something I had not less so now but it's
something I had um it's me it's an
interesting thing to talk about because
it strikes me that your journey will be
the worst bit will be when you've got
one
kid why you almost want twins off the
bat why because your story is an only
child that needs to connect yeah so it's
a weird thing when you have two the dark
thought you have when you have two is
well if anything happens to us at least
they got each other and you don't even
have a sister to we've established
this tried
tried
yeah yeah it's I I kind of think that's
is that not the journey though is that
not the thing of going and the the
quiet the the kind of the listening that
you've done for the first five six years
of this podcast I feel like that's going
to remain and then there'll be another
gear where you're on send yeah I feel
like that you know it's often easier to
see in other people like of what the
trajectory of their career will
be because it's like it's kind of your
you're in training to be a wise man
you're a bit Young wise man in training
but you're a bit young to be a wise man
right but that's kind of where it's I
have a friend you know David Perell
really good follow on Twitter if no one
if people aren't following him um he was
the one that wrote
the the article uh think like an athlete
which in classic Twitter fashion I
didn't read read the headline made up my
own idea about what the article was
about and then that ended up being
really form
so he didn't write an article that ended
up being very formative to me what I
ended hang on what's what's untrue but
yeah yeah yeah fig figuratively false
but literally true or the reverse yeah
so he uh first off he he was one of the
people that poked me toward turning pro
with the show what would happen if I
treated the pursuit of being a podcaster
like athletes do where I review game
tape and I get a speech coach an
addiction coach and a comedy coach and I
do improv and I go to bed on time and
I'm hydrated and I learn how the mouth
moves and all of these things what would
happen if I did that and it worked out
to be really great from one sentence
think like an athlete which wasn't the
what the article was about right
but he uh is in this great relationship
he lives in Austin and he we we had a
phone call before I even moved to Austin
you tell me this this really beautiful
sentiment you know he's worked an awful
lot throughout his 20s very successful
spent a lot of time thinking and being
around people and networking and doing
self-work and meditation and you know
he's had he got a Rabbi that he
goes and sees at 6 a.m. every Saturday
CU he wants to learn about Jewish Cannon
and he said everything I've done in my
20s Was preparing me to be the dad that
I wanted to be you know you got this guy
who's got million dollars and million
million million people business all this
stuff and he was like yeah it's just in
service of becoming the dad that I
wanted to be and I thought that was a
really beautiful sentiment I've always
known I haven't always known that I
wanted to be a dad I always had a sense
that I wanted to be a dad and then
definitely the last five years I just I
I can't wait to be a dad so yeah it's
nice it's nice to know that even though
the kid isn't there ready for you to
bestow the hard work and the fruits of
your labor internally externally on yeah
you kind of you're kind of doing it for
them in a way yeah I could see that I
could I mean it's also that thing if you
go it's the it's the role that you want
to play and you don't know yourself yet
the interesting thing is like it's
interesting to think about getting to
know your kid CU your kid the kid
arrives and they go I haven't really met
them
yet you want you're going to meet them
at some point you know meet them and
connect with them and you know great you
and you get a sense of who they are but
it's it's bit by bit but then you
haven't had you don't have a sense of
who you are as a
dad and it's interesting what would you
be
like
fritzel yeah very good at DIY no one
talks about that I can't put a shelf
I can't put a sh up he built a house
under his house props I've heard you
talk about enjoying the passage of time
as a good synopsis well I think anything
where you're in a flow State seems to be
a magical time so what you know your
whether it's a hobby or a or your job
ideally but something where you're in a
in a flow state so good conversation is
kind of Flow State right so I'm not
quite sure how long we been talking I'm
sure listeners are going well too long
frankly but
it's you're kind of in a flow you're
you're in a flow you're enjoying it
you're not looking at the clock you're
not conscious of other things you're
just where you are yeah and focused so
on stage I find that's a flow State
playing tennis I really like I'm not
that good at tennis but I really like
playing it and that thing of like when
you're doing sports I suppose it lifts
the anxiety because the thing that we
talked about anxiety is solving future
problems ahead of time and when you're
doing something in a flow State you're
in it you're dealing with that thing
you've your conscious mind is busy and
it's just for the purpose of that as
well you know going back to the telic
and anti- telic tiic and anti- teic
stuff yeah pickle ball for me is my it's
just it's so rapid and so all consuming
that I can't I can't think about
anything else and you know so that's
switching off yeah yeah great I think
some I think you need something like
that as well something that's uh low
stakes a flow State that's low stakes in
life you you're not bothered about the
outcome oh that's interesting you're not
becoming a professional pickle ball
player you are a professional podcaster
this is a flow state but it's high
stakes this matters to you greatly but
to have something where you go it's
really just for fun I'm not trying to
get better at this like you in the gym
you're trying to achieve something
aesthetically physically healthwise
probably less healthwise and more
aesthetically in your 20s and as you get
older it be more Health but that idea of
going what's something you could enjoy
be in a flow State and it's just fun
low stakes flow state is a lovely
framework that I haven't thought about
before that a lot of people will
continue to pile high stakes onto the
thing that they choose to
do and I don't know if that fully
encapsulates the relaxation that you
have you know it may be able to drill
your focus even more you may be
completely dialed in and and very very
concerned about the
outcome but I don't know
if it achieves everything that you
could from this variety this sort of
relaxation this very sort of
parasympathetic I'm just at ease here I
lose the game of pickle ball my friend
Aaron calls me a so what like it's
you know it is what it is
yeah but his parents never loved him
anyway look how far they got in the book
of boys
names that'll
do he is currently in New York and he's
become the director of director of
physical therapy for the Aaron roders
the current best living
quarterback in all of the NFL so he
plays for the New York Jets right uh I
think and probably just easier if every
on the team's called
Aron just honestly he's not the best
he's just he's less fuss Aaron Aaron has
been hit in the head too many times he
can remember the name Aaron so we have
to hire an Aaron if you shout Aaron 50
people turn around well the quarterback
doesn't he just sort of has to right
okay yeah yeah yeah but no he's uh he's
over there but yeah doing something
that's that's low stakes that's Flow
State I I think that that's a really
nice conception and it's like a good
justification for having Hobbies you
know yeah I mean that that we need a
justification is really speaks to our
the the activity I mean I I really
guilty of this like even when you go on
holiday you make a list of books to read
when you're away to relax like its
homework but that's you know really the
only thing I got from my education was
work ethic you know you you find what
your work ethic is when you find what
you love doing but then it's it's hard
not to replicate that in all areas of
your
life productivity Purgatory was what I
called it that even even when you're
supposed to be doing something for
leisure it's still in service of the
outcomes that you're going to get at
work so it's the walk that you take on a
morning not because you get to relax and
spend time in nature but because you
heard an Andrew huberman episode about
how it improves dopamine the
dopaminergic sees saw so you can focus
better the wonderful thing about being a
comedian I mean I could be getting a
colonoscopy and thinking well there
might be some material in this you never
know literally you never know a virtual
colonoscopy the future maybe a VR one
where they fly a tiny little Micro Drone
up
yeah that's what he told me anyway we're
in a
park what have you got coming up next
what can people expect from you I've got
a new tour I'm going to go out on the
road again I'm touring slightly
differently this time I hope it works uh
I think it will but certainly around the
UK I'm going to do two shows a night
every night Wednesday to Saturday so
work less and more than I've worked
before I'm going to do more shows but
more compacted and I'm going to do a
show at 7 and a show at 9:30 I'm a Big
Show at 7 fan by the way well it's that
thing if you either have dinner
afterwards or before you either have
drinks after or before but you go it's
not a big with an interval it's like you
pack the stuff in you know do maybe 100
minutes got time to do 100 maybe even
two hours sort of straight through and
that's a it's a great show to hold
people for that long it's great you
don't because they break and then you
build it again and with the bigger shows
sometimes you just do it with a regular
interval but I'm you know putting that
tour on I'm working on a book at the
moment it's probably the easiest
conception of it about how to write
jokes I've had a really great run in
comedy and what am I leaving for
posterity some dick jokes right I right
lovely jokes I've done a bunch of
specials uh I'll record a new one next
month I don't know when it be out but I
want to leave something behind to the
community because it's done an awful lot
for me so I'm working on this thing and
hopefully it'll become something for you
know other comedians America you doing
America yeah doing a tour in America
sort of gigging around the place I mean
it's you know it's quite nice it's I can
play quite big rooms it turns out that
because of the one of the major benefits
of the the biggest TV channel in the
world is YouTube and no one noticed in
mainstream media no one noticed oh
that's the biggest TV channel in the
world so your Netflix and your YouTubes
the global entities mean you can play
anywhere in the world which is fantastic
I do about 40
countries and I'll Do America and I'll
play cities I've never been to and 2,000
people will turn up it's amazing I'm
looking forward to Austin Sunday the
something of October Sunday maybe the
17th of October it's somewhere in there
Jimmy I really appreciate you I I we got
introduced by a mutual friend yeah and I
feel like
uh it's a real flourishing blossoming
it's lovely I I'm a huge fan of this
please don't stop and please do more I
think more conversations and more more
learning and it uh yeah it grows corn
it's a great show I appreciate you thank
you mate thanks thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
with Jimmy you are going to love my
conversation with Mark Norman go on
press
it